et j'appelle le premier orateur de la
discussion générale la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-François Rousset pour le
groupe
Renaissance
alors est-ce qu'il est il était il était
là tout à l'heure il est là
DESC monsieur Rousset
arrive sil vous s'il vous plaît monsieur
Rousset va s'exprimer merci pour
lui je peux y
aller madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les
ministres madame la Présidente de la
Commission madame la rapporteur général
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
chers collègues s'il fallait un mot pour
qualifier le budget santé 2024 je
retiendrai le mot
prévention un mot qui traduit la
capacité de nos politiques à maintenir
nos concitoyens en bonne santé quand on
soignera jamais mieux un patient qu'en
lui donnant les moyens de s'informer de
suivre sa santé
ainsi que les outils permettant
d'améliorer son hygiène de
vie tous autant que nous sommes nous
pouvons et nous devons être attentifs au
risqu en santé selon les âges selon les
métiers selon les rythmes individuels
selon les handicaps il est possible d'
d'identifier les menaces qui pèsent sur
notre santé
allons-y la recherche progresse
faisons-lui confiance les vaccins ARN on
en fait la preuve pendant l'épidémie de
la covid
grâce à elle nous disposons de moyens de
prévention avec ce budget 2024 nous nous
donnons les moyen d'agir s'il fallait
être concis et si on devait par les
chiffres je reetindrai cette phrase
prévenir c'est investir 1 € aujourd'hui
pour éviter 10 € de dépenses curativ
demê chers collègues ce budget s'inscrit
en pleine cohérence avec notre stratégie
de long terme dès 2017 la définition une
stratégie nationale de santé a permis de
resserrer le nombre des objectifs de nos
politiques de prévention je note que la
Cour des comptes en souligne la
pertinence et
l'efficacité dès 2017 nous avons adopté
une une approche interministérielle qui
crée de la
transversalité réforme dans le Haut
conseil de santé publique a appuyé
l'intérêt une mise en cohérence qui
s'est traduite par une simplification
institutionnelle aboutissant à la
création de santé publique par la fusion
de plusieurs autorités adistrative
existante chers collègues ce buget
permet de construire l'avenir tout en
consolidant nos acquis nous avons
développer des dispositifs
d'expérimentation pour tester et par la
suite évaluer des nouvelles méthodes et
des outils innovants nombre d'entre eux
se sont avérés utiles et efficaces alors
généralisons-les ces expériences
réussies qui permettent de garantir une
mise en œuvre opérationnel au plus juste
et au plus proches des besoins ainsi
préciser ce qui fait l'ambition de de ce
de ce budget et sur ce point je souhaite
souligner la grande implication des
ministres concernés auprès des
parlementaires inter intéressonsnous
maintenant aux mesures de
prévention en premier la généralisation
de la vaccination contre le papilloma
virus dans les collèges qui vont
permettre de prévenir 90 % des
infections chaque année elles sont à
l'origine de 6400 cas de cancer du colle
de l'utérus en particulier c'est aussi
la prévention des maladies sexuellement
transmissible pour nos jeunes avec la
prise en charge intégrale des
préservatifs pour les moins de 26 ans
c'est aussi la précision des modalités
d'organisation des rendez-vous de
prévention pour en favoriser l'accès et
l'efficacité ensuite pour ce qui
concerne l'accès au au soins la
définition du cadre permettant la mise
en place de parcours coordonnés renforcé
permettant la prise en charge de patient
dans sa globalité par la coopération des
professionnels de santé c'est aussi la
régulation de la permanence soin fait
par les chirurgiens dentistes don les
expérimentations déjà effectué ont
montré d'efficacité c'est la délivrance
antibiotique directement en pharmacie
après
le l'utilisation d'un trot pour traiter
les cistites ou les Angeline une une
simplification pour les malades et un
temps gagn pour nos médecins c'est aussi
l'obligation pour les pour les
pharmaciens de délivrer des
antibiotiques à l'unité en cas de
rupture d'approvisionnement par pénurie
l'incitation donnée aux entreprises
productrices de médicaments à chercher
un repreneur en cas de commercialisation
bien sûr c'est aussi un sujet de
souveraineté de
relocalisation la revalorisation des
salaires dans les établissements de
santé et le plan d'attractivité pour le
personnel hospitalier ce sont
respectivement 1,7 milliards et 1,
milliards d'euros qui sont consacrés
sortir du tout et de an en proposant un
système de financement qui permet de
mieux considérer l'ensemble de la prise
en charge des patients sur ensemble de
ces sujets force de constater que
l'opposition s'est encore une fois
montrée dogmatique en rejetant
l'essentiel de ces mesures autant de
mesures qui font pourtant l'objet d'un
large consensus auprès de concitoyens et
des professionnels du monde de la santé
dans la ligée du groupe Renaissance
proposons d'aller encore plus loin si le
texte prévoit dans l'intégration de
plusieurs allocataire dont le bénéfice
de la complémentaire santé nous
proposons de réfléchir à l'intégration
des étudiants boursier en 2015 déjà 8 %
de ces étudiants n'avaient pas de mutuel
aujourd'hui ça serait près de 20 % en
assurant un accès aux soins pour les
plus jeunes nous garantissons là aussi
une meilleure santé pour
l'avenir nous défendons également la
prise en charge de l'activité physique
adaptée il s'agit d'une thérapie non
médicamenteuse qui a fait ses preuves
sur la prévention de la prévalence des
maladies chronique et qui s'inscrit dans
le progrès d'une année sportive à venir
ensuite c'est le dépistage prén
obligatoire du COM mégalovirus qui
touche 5 à nouveau nés sur 100 sur 1000
ou encore la vaccination contre le
papioma virus pour les jeunes en
situation de handicap tout cela sont
autant d'avancés que nous sommes fiers
de porter au côté du gouvernement enfin
nous défendons aussi un dépissage
bucdentaire des populations âgées et
handicapées dans les établissements
médicaux sociaux ce dépissage
permettrait d'éviter des soins futurs et
coûteux d'améliorer le bien-être de
limiter les coûts de transport et de
corriger par exemple les erreurs
diagnostiques quand une douleur est mal
exprimée et qu'elle oriente vers la
psychiatrie vous l'aurez compris à
travers toutes ces mesures ce PLFSS 2024
fait le choix de l'efficience apporter
des réponses concrètes tout en assurant
un équilibre financier péren une assise
financière consolidée témoigne
l'objectif d'un retour à moins de 3 % de
déficit dès 2027
une rigueur quant à la bonne gestion des
données publiques qui se traduit aussi
par un renforcement de la lutte contre
la fraude pour 2024 l'objectif est
fixé fixé d'atteindre une réduction des
fraudes à hauteur de 500 millions
d'euros pour la branche maladie un choix
politique évident dans mon groupe que
mon groupe soutient la montée en charge
en lien étroit avec le ministère des
comptes publics nous ne permettrons plus
que les professionnels de santé dont la
pratique fruleuse ont été identifié
puiss Contin continu à bénéficier de la
participation de l'Assurance Maladie
pour leur pement de leur cotisation
c'est un motif d'exemplarité nécessaire
vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens pendant la
crise sanitaire nous avons déployé des
moyens importants pour protéger notre
pays aujourd'hui la pérenité de notre
modèle social suppose de la précision il
nous faut dépenser au plus juste un
fondamental que nous devons désormais
considérer essentiel à not système de
solidarité ce texte est donc un projet
équilibré est responsable qui garantit
le maintien de notre système social il
est à l'image de l'ambition que nous
avons pour not pour une meilleure santé
c'est pourquoi le groupe Renaissance
votera en faveur du PLFSS 2024 je vous
remercie merci
merci la parole est à Madame Joë Mélin
pour le groupe rassemblement
national
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministre ou monsieur le
ministre madame la rapporteur générale
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
thématiques madame la Présidente de la
Commission et mes chers collègues grande
première en commission des affaires
sociales le rejet de votre PLFSS 2024
c'est normal puisqu'il repose sur une
obsolescence stratégique
ahurissante en effet il répond à une
norme fixée il y a 43 ans dans des
conventions de mai 1980 qui créent la
maîtrise comptable je cite la
revalorisation des prescriptions et des
honoraires se fera en fonction des
recettes disponibles de l'Assurance
Maladie tout était dit pour le
demi-siècle suivant un manque total
d'ambition et d'adéquation avec les
besoins car cette norme n'a jamais été
réévaluée nous constatons une pénurie
humaine dans la totalité des filières de
soignants et desidents un manque de
moyens financiers criant pour la
médecine de ville pour les hôpitaux
publics et privés pour le médico social
pour nos épades les deux symboles en
sont les deux extrêmes de la vie en en
néonatologie ce sont 1200 nouveau nés
fragiles qui selon une étude récente
n'ont pu être sauvés faute de moyens
nous faisant passer de la 3e à la 20e
place de la mortalité infantile et à
l'autre bout c'est l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé qui recule pourtant les
prélèvements sont là sur les 602
milliards pour 2023 qui auraiit dû
suffire si on était revenu à l'esprit
même de notre sécurité sociale et cyberc
ne laissaiit pas filer la dette tolérant
une gestion catastrophique et bien pire
imposant en même temps l'austorité dès
lors empêtré comme vous l'êtes dans un
piège que vous vous êtes vous-même tendu
vous n'avez plus d'autre choix qu'un
bidouillage de transfert de comptes un
financement toujours plus fiscalisé ou
un retours massif à la dette alors qu'il
faudrait de l'ambition et du dynamisme
et les quelques propositions auxquelles
nous avons adhéré le dépistage du citô
mgalovirus l'octroit de la
complémentaire solidarité au plus fragil
les gardes dentaires ne sont que des
broutilles face aux besoins réels des
Français sur la forme la discussion en
commission a été marquée par
l'incroyable psychorigidité des
rapporteurs 94 amendements seulement
adoptés sur les plus de 1200 discutés
pourquoi présenter des amendements dans
ces conditions et que dire si même le
sujet était très important de la
prévention des maladies sexuellement
transmissibles qui ont pris plus de 5 %
de notre temps pas une seconde sur les
déserts médicaux ni sur les déserts
pharmaceutiques sur l'état de faillite
de beaucoup de nu urgen pas non plus de
débat sur le tiers de nos hôpitaux en
quasi dépôts de bilan et sur les épades
qui ne savent même pas comment payer
leur facture d'électricité cet hiver sur
le fond la situation a vraiment de quoi
inquiéter car vous nous dites concernant
l'article liminaire et les tableaux
d'équilibre qu'il s'agit de photographie
à prendre ou à laisser bien sûr que non
il s'agit avant tout de grossierers
photomontage et oné falsificateur de la
réalité un photomondage sur
2023 l'article liminminire est censé
donner confiance à qui sans doute aux
investisseurs privés acteurs de
financiarisation que vous semblez
découvrir monsieur le ministre et qui
est déjà très avancé et ils sont à
l'affut de même que les agences de
notation tout cela cache mal un socle
2022 totalement crédité par la Cour des
comptes qui a rejeté la branche famille
pour une erreur irrattrapable de 5
milliards 8 voyez du peu certifier les
autres branches avec 11 anomalies
comptables graves et 43 insuffisances
d'éléments promants discrédité par les
deux assemblées qui ont refusé
d'approuver le budget global discrédité
par la sortie du périmètre des assauts
du fond de réserve des retraites et de
la cadesse non consolidé dans les compte
de l'État qui cache très mal le
financement de la sécurité sociale par
la dette même photomontage pour
l'article 1 d'équilibre des comptes qui
dangereusement ne prend pas en compte la
totalité du périmètre pertinent
photomontage aussi au motif de la lutte
tout à fait légitime contre la fraude en
vous trompant siamment je me pose la
question de méthodes et de ciblebles
vous ne faites qu'ajouter à la confusion
au statut de subordination entre les
auto-entrepreneurs et les plateformes
qui les rémunèrent sans régler le
problème de la fraude confusion sur la
rémunération des actes
pluridisciplinaires de santé en faisant
fi d'accords conventionnels et on verra
peut-être un peu plus tard être sûr que
vous n'allez pas vous imisser dans les
les caisses complémentaires d'argir kaco
et cela aussi en faisant un mixte
compliqué en mélangeant le financement
des hôpitaux sans véritablement trancher
sur la T2A fontom montage aussi pour
2024 ce PLFSS pour 3 ans est le moins
solide depuis
1997 la trajectoire en est non maîtrisée
passant d'un déficit prévisionnel de 10
à 18 milliards sans visibilité de retour
à l'équilibre les prévision visions
macro-économiqu à court terme sont
irréalistes la croissance 2024 sera de
la vie quasi unanime proche de 1 plutôt
que des 14 que vous nous avancez et
l'inflation aura beaucoup de mal à
passer de 2 de 5 à 2 et demi comment
ainsi pilonter un N d'âme recevable et
qui est déjà manifestement sous-évalué
votre budget manque de sérieux en
prévoyant une évolution tendantielle
faible des dépenses cela ne nous met
absolument pas à l'abri d'une éventuelle
catastrophe sanitaire le saupoudrage que
vous pratiquez dans de très nombreux
domaines se par essence même inefficient
sur les comptes globaux vous identifiez
des mesures d'économie mais on sait bien
que plus de la moitié ne sera ni
appliqué ni à force réévalué concernant
les différentes branches vous souhaitez
manifestement les fondre les unes dans
les autres pour masquer un peu plus les
transferts de comblement de déficit vous
sacrifiez l'innovation sur l'Hôtel des
mauvaises économies vous laissez à la
cadesse donc aux enfants d'aujourd'hui
le soin de payer les dettes d'hier
d'aujourd'hui et de demain et vous y
ajouz bien évidemment des mauvaises
solutions d'économie en pensant qu'on
pourrait faire des transports partagés
je vous rappelle que c'était
manifestement un objet de fraude jusqu'à
hier avant la décision que vous
présentez ou c'est des soins dentaires
ou la biologie qui verront encore leur
marge de manœuvre
diminué et cela malgré vos promesses
depuis 11 ans vous retardez toujours le
moment de grande politique globale par
une gesticulation d'ffets d'annonce
veain de mesurettes au final
mine de rien très déstabilisante pour
l'équilibre du système ces grandes
politiques que le rassemblement national
mettra en place en fonction des besoins
non compatriotes et non des moyens
jamais maîtrisés nous souhaitons à
l'opposé de votre inaction y substituer
l'ambition et le dynamisme à titre
d'exemple une grande politique de la
santé publique et distribution de soins
solides fondée sur l'égalité
territoriale en pensant aux zones
rurales et périphériques et surtout à
nos ultremes parallèlement renforcer le
renouvellement des générations de
soisignant avec la levée de tous les
numérus avec des professionnels bien
formés justement rémunérés dans des
filières attractives et qui ne soient
pas étranglé par des charges indu
totalement méconnu de votre hâme en les
libérant d'une bureaucratisation
étouffante en ville comme à l'hôpital
nous en dont nous rééquilibrerons le
financement nous faciliterons le
désengorgement des urgences par une
meilleure coopération entre la ville et
l'hôpital nous nous occuperons de
clarifier la gestion des comptes et nous
combattrons les fraudes dont le recours
gouvernement stragne lamentablement à
moins d'un milliard alors qu'il y a déjà
15 ans que le député tiant les estimé à
10 milliards et le juge Prats
aujourd'hui à 30 ou 40 milliards il
n'est pourtant pas difficile me
semble-t-il de se rendre à 6h du matin
devant les plateformes de BTP et de voir
qui embauche qui à la journée en
transformant aussi l'ame en soin
réservés aux seules urgences comme cela
se fait dans tous les pays européens en
finalisant la politique de soins
palliatifs dans notre pays qui reste cru
uellement en retard nous ouvrerons aussi
pour la médecine scolaire la santé
mentale des enfants et des adolescents
notre médecine du travail et tous les
risques et afférant en un mot pour la
prévention nous aurons aussi une grande
politique de l'emploi pour pour tous les
actifs de 18 à 64 ans pour ne laisser
personne sur le chemin permettre à tous
de cotiser dans le cadre d'une
solidarité universelle nous débusquerons
les trappes à basalaire sur des emplois
peu attractifs afin de limiter le
recours à l'immigration le levier de la
réindustrie étion sera centrale à cette
ambition de souveraineté industrielle et
pharmaceutique sans oublier le levier de
la recherche pour laquelle la crise du
covid a largement montré notre retard
nous soutiendrons aussi une grande
politique familiale globale et
ambitieuse par différentes mesures dont
la priorité à l'universalité des
allocations familiales un nécessaire
retour à la confiance concernant la
politique familiale et sa lisibilité
dans le temps long un ajustement au
mieux des dispositifs de conciliation
professionnel et fe familial et nous
permettrons enfin un grand plan d'étude
sur les raisons d'une infertilité
inquiétante qui touche toute la
population enfin nous mettrons en place
une grande politique du grand âge et de
la perte d'onomie avec une vraie
stratégie et une vraie gouvernance
qu'est-ce que ce système où la la CNSA
subventionne les conseils généraux
départementaux et qui donneent leur
dossierers à gérer pour tièr aux caisses
d'allocation familiale on croit rêver au
développement de structure d'accueil
plus humanisé plus pr de la notion de
domicile personnel et non de mourroir au
développement de l'accessibilité des
handicapés au services numériques
toujours très déficitaire et nous
réajusterons aussi l'amendement Creton
alors tout cela n'est pas une l exustive
de nos propositions mais elles sont bien
symboliques de ce que nous proposons
alors nous disons non à votre
recentralisation repente qui bien sûr
prépare un terrain planifié pour les
grands groupes plédateurs de demain et
nous disons OUI à une protection sociale
à la française pour tous les Français je
vous remercie je vous remerci
merci nous poursuivons cette discussion
générale avec Monsieur Damien maudé pour
le groupe la France insoumis pour une
durée de 10
[Applaudissements]
minutes
madame la
Présidente Mesdames messieurs les
ministres mesdames Messieurs les
rapporteurs chers
collègues la fatigue est présente
l'angoisse est là pour les soignants
mais à l'issue de cette crise un plan
d'investissement massif sera construit
pour notre hôpital la Nation toute
entière est derrière reconnaissante en
2020 Emmanuel Macron annoncé un plan
massif d'investissement en 2023 on ne
parle plus d'investissement massif mais
vous mesdames messieurs les ministres
monsieur le ministre de la Santé vous
parlez d'une trajectoire responsable une
trajectoire responsable qui s'inscrit
dans la longue lignée des trajectoires
responsable que les soignants patients
travailleurs travailleurs ont dû subir
la vérité c'est que sur le fond comme
sur la forme la trajectoire que vous
nous proposez n'a rien de responsable
vous continuez d'étouffer à coup de
budget amaigri un système de santé qui
ne tient déjà plus mesdames messieurs
les ministres vous opposez une
trajectoire responsable à des supposés
irresponsables mais les irresponsables
c'est
vous déjà déjà que faisons-nous
ici toute la semaine dernière nous avons
étudié votre proposition de budget
responsable pour la sécurité sociale et
pour la première fois de toute
l'histoire des lois de financement de la
sécurité sociale ce budget a été rejeté
ce budget est
tellement ce budget est tellement
responsable que vos propres députés ont
pris leur responsabilité et ne sont même
pas venus le voter en toute logique si
vous étiez un démocrate responsable vous
devriez prendre acte le budget proposé
n'est pas à la hauteur vous avez perdu
le vote et vous devriez revoir votre
copie au lieu de ça vous revenez avec le
même texte que celui que nous avons
rejeté et la première ministre va venir
prendre ses responsabilités pour sauver
pour vous sauver et passer ce budget par
la force par 493 faute d'avoir su
convaincre l'opposition mais même vos
propres députés on est passé du
renouveau au dénis démocratique les
irresponsables c'est
vous c'est une irresponsabilité que vous
pratiquez depuis plusieurs années durant
le covid je travaillais avec des sacs
poubelles j'ai acheté une charlotte
jetable au supermarché on avait pas de
masque FFP2 alors je mettais quatre
masques chirurgicaux mais ça ne m'a pas
empêché d'attraper le covid Sarah quand
elle travaillait en épad à limoge elle
elle a pris ses responsabilités malgré
le covid malgré la peur elle est aller
au travail pour s'occuper de nos aînés s
Pararé elle a laissé son fils pendant 2
mois pour ne pas le contaminer pour elle
un déchirement au cœur mais pour faire
battre le cœur de la nation en tête elle
avait sans doute les promesses du
Président l'investissement massif la
nation reconnaissante elle attendit le
moment où elle serait remerciée où on
aurait reconnu son sens des
responsabilités mais visiblement le sens
des responsabilités ça n'est que pour
les soignants parce que depuis le covid
mesdames messieurs les ministres c'est
l'enfer c'est l'enfer et c'est de pire
en pire Sébastien infirmier Abrest
m'explique depuis 30 ans je n'ai jamais
vu autant de gens demander des
disponibilités énormément de jeunes
entre 25 et 35 ans prennent des
disponibilités j'ai des collègues qui
partent ouvrir des foot truck ou des
restaurants vous avez été tellement
responsable que selon le syndicat
infirmier SNPI nous sommes passés de
7500 postes vacants en 2020 à 60000 en
2022 une multiplication par 8 en 2 ans
c'est la grande fuite des soignants
faute de consididération faute de
reconnaissance faute de revalorisation
alors qu'ils ne demandent qu'un peu de
dessence ils partent ils partent et ceux
qui restent sont en train de subir ils
aiment leur boulot mais vous leur faites
faire le pire et c'est le pire partout
en pédiatrie c'est la catastrophe à
Paris on nous a dit même pendant le
covid on n' pas ventilé dans les
services d'urgence maintenant on ventile
des enfants dans les couloirs à Orléan
Grégory nous raconte depuis l'année
dernière on a dû fermer quatre lits en
réanimation pédiatrique à cause du
manque de pédiatre c'était nos seuls
lits donc notre service a fermé
maintenant s'il y a une urgence les
enfants devront aller se faire soigner à
tour ou à Paris à 1h30 de route et dans
le même temps la mortalité infantile ne
recule plus dans notre pays vous rendez
compte la mortalité infantile ne recule
plus dans notre pays nous sommes passés
de 3e à 20e de l'Union européenne et P
en ce temps-là 10000 soignants ont
interpellé le président l'année dernière
et depuis que s'est-il passé rien dans
les services d'urgence partout des
fermetures et vous préférez appeler ça
des régulations mais la réalité reste la
même les urgences ne sont plus
accessibles à tout le monde faute de
personnel à Saint-Junien à carré à
Bagnol à Mayenne ou àertui je pourrais
vous citer un tas d'exemples partout
dans le pays où les gens n'ont plus
accès aux urgences parfois le jour mais
souvent la nuit le syndicat SAMU urgence
de France explique qu'un service sur
deux a été fermé totalement ou
partiellement cet été
dans les services ouverts les patients
patientent mais les soignants ont du mal
à soigner à limoge des patients sont
gardés aux urgences durant 9 jours
encore hier je recevé un mail qui a été
envoyé au cadre de santé je cite notre
service accueille ce soir 88 personnes
88 personnes il y a 15 box pour
accueillir les gens aux urgences à
l'imeuge à Strasbourg l'hôpital
fonctionne à 193 % de ses capacités et
le personnel craque on est dans une
situation de guerre permanente il y a
plein de choses qui nous échappent
aujourd'hui dire venez aux urgences vous
serez pris en charge c'est un mensonge
désespère un médecin et Sébastien de
Brest me raconte de nouveau imaginez la
dernière fois j'ai surpris une soignante
en train de pleurer c'était la patiente
qui était en train de la
réconforter lorsque le syndicat SAMU
urgence de France annonce 150 décès
inattendu sur un mois en 2022 quand la
CGT annonce plus de 1000 décès
inattendus en un an plutôt que d'ouvrir
les yeux vous nous avez répondu que ces
chiffres était honteux mais ce qui est
honteux c'est la position que vous
adoptez les irresponsables c'est
vous
monsieur le
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres quand on vient avec un bilan
comme celui-là c'est pas un 493 qu'il
faut nous présenter ce sont des excuses
au lieu de ça rien vous poursuivez dans
la même logique dans la même pensée
dogmatique et il y aura les mêmes
résultats catastrophiques alors que 60 %
des infirmières disent qu'elles veulent
changer de métier vous proposez un texte
avec 100 fois le mot économie une seule
fois hôpital public alors que les
établissements de santé public comme
privé n'arrivve plus à joindre les
debouts vous proposez un budget dans
lequel il manque 3,5 milliards d'euros
ne serait-ce que pour payer la hausse
des salaires et compenser l'inflation
malgré ça vous passez en force un budget
rejeté par la Fédération Hospitalière la
CGT la FNI la snil la CFDT les
mutualités franceassau santé et même à
la Caisse nationale d'assurance maladie
personne n'a voté pour ce
budget je vous le redemande est-ce que
cela vous semble responsable vous êtes
minoritaire dans les institutions mais
aussi dans la rue au moment où l'on se
parle il y avait des soyants de toute la
France qui étaient venus devant
l'Assemblée pour manifester avec le Tour
de France de la santé des manifestations
ont eu lieu partout dans le pays à à
Saint-Junien à Langre à Quimper à
guingan partout les Français vous le
disent les irresponsables c'est
vous
mais Monsieur le Ministre mesdames
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
peut-être n'avons-nous simplement pas la
même définition de la responsabilité par
exemple sur les médicaments sur les
médicaments être responsable pour nous
c'est permettre à chacun de se soigner
et garantir la production et
l'approvisionnement de nos médicaments
essentiels pour vous c'est prendre
conseil ou plutôt vos consignes auprès
d'un groupe d'experts composés de
représentants de l'industrie
pharmaceutique et ainsi proposer 300
millions d'euros de cadeaux au labo tout
en faisant payer les Français plus chers
sur l'hôpital estêtre responsable pour
nous c'est offrir au soignants des
conditions de travail et des
rémunérations dignes permettre à tous
les Français d'être soignés correctement
pour vous c'est faire plus de 3
milliards d'euros d'économie sur le
budget des hôpitaux car il faut bien que
quelqu'un les paye ces 80 milliards
d'euros qui manque de manque à gagner
pour la sécurité sociale que vous avez
octroyé en exonération de cotisation
sociale je traduis donc votre définition
de la responsabilité que chaque que
chaque Français se sert la ceinture
chaque jour un peu plus et que pour que
le gouvernement puisse continuer à
arroser d'argent public les plus riches
et les plus grandes entreprises de ce
pays mais mais dans cette quête pour
détruire la SQ je dois reconnaître vous
n'êtes pas seul vous n'êtes pas seul
puisque vous avez pu trouver
d'excellents alliés durant la Commission
à savoir le rassemblement national
franchement vous êtes incroyable vous
vous voulez sauver l'hôpital mais sans
argent vous voulez être les défenseurs
des services publics et du système de
santé mais dès qu'il faut voter vous
renoncez pour financer les épes on vous
a proposé 1 % sur les 10 % les plus
riches vous renoncez vous sauvez les
puissants contre nos aînés tous les
groupe d'opposition demande à ce que
chaque exonération soit compensée y
compris la droite et vous vous renoncez
vous avez sauvé le gouvernement plutôt
que la sécurité sociale plutôt que
l'intérêt national franchement
franchement changez de nom changez de
nom vous n'êtes pas le rassemblement
national vous êtes le renoncement
national et une fois de plus on vous
retrouve main dans la main avec les
macronistes pour détruire notre
protection sociale du Ren à la macronie
les responsables et les irresponsables
c'est vous pourtant d'autres avant vous
avaient des des horizons plus désirables
ras croisa créateur de la sécurité
sociale disait à cette même tribune avec
de telles institutions nous pouvons
avoir la certitude que la sécurité
sociale sera en constant progrès elle
sera une création continue et elle
aidera puissamment notre pays à
améliorer son état sanitaire tout en
libérant l'ensemble des Français des
incertitudes de l'avenir certains ont eu
des rêves et mais on
réalisé eux ils ont pris leur
responsabilité permettre à tous les
Français d'être soignés aux travailleurs
des établissements de santé d'être fiers
de leur métier les soignants les
Français ont besoin d'un peu d'espoir
mais vous vous prolongez le cauchemar et
ça mesdames et messieurs les ministres
ça c'est
irresponsable je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Yannick nuder pour le groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républiqu
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres messieurs et mesames les
rapporteurs madame la rapporteur
générale madame la Présidente de
commission nous l'avons dit le compte
n'y'est pas et la situation est
relativement historique puisque en
commission des affaires sociales le
PLFSS 2024 n'a pas été adopté
c'est une c'est un signal fort que nous
avons souhaité envoyer au gouvernement
sur un PLFSS qui a été construit sans
aucune concertation et sans écoute de
son opposition les hypothèses sur lequel
vous avez bâti londam sont
malheureusement insincèr vous basez vos
chiffres sur une croissance à 1,4 %
alors que la BCE prévoit 75 % de
différence à 0,9 % et une inflation à
2,5 alors que la BCE prévoit une
inflation à 3,2 %. le compte n'y est pas
non plus sur la famille qui en 2023
était la variable d'ajustement avec une
ponction de plus de 2 milliards d'euros
nous faisons un bénéfice du doute pour
la ministre berger pour rétablir
l'universalité des allocations
familiales j'espère qu'elle pourra le
confirmer puisque nous le savons cette
mesure supprimée par François Hollande
en 2012 a montré ses effets avec un taux
de natalité le plus bas depuis 1945 avec
ne serait-ce que sur le 1ier semestre
2023 - 25 000 naissances concernant
l'amendement Creton nous nous félicitons
effectivement de voir la création de
10000 places pour sortir ces personnes
des places dans les centres d'handicapés
pour réserver pour nos enfants enfin
concernant l'autonomie le compte n'y est
pas non plus puisque malgré les 0,15
points de CSG qui viendront en janvier
le 2,6 milliards ne suffira pas à
financer la totalité de cette 5è branche
en effet le reste à charge moyen pour
une personne âgée en est pas d' 1000 €
moyen par par foyer ce qui est
extrêmement important et nous nous avons
fait un certain nombre de propositions
sur des moyens de financement que ça
soit le système assurantiel que ça soit
par capitalisation en lien avec la
Mutualité Française pour l'instant nous
sommes rester sans écoute de savoir quel
financement nous souhaitons pour quel
niveau d'autonomie en en sachant que le
le le virage domiciliaire est important
qu'il estit le choix de vie d'un certain
nombre de nos concitoyens mais pour cela
il faut 380000 personnes en formation
pour les acteurs du domicile et que la
loi bien vieillir pour l'instant ne
pourvoit rien dans ces besoin de
formation des 380000 personnes enfin sur
le PLFSS nous n'avons rien vu non plus
sur les soins palliatif je rappelle
qu'il y a encore 21 départements qui
sont dépourvus d'unités de soins
palliatif donc monsieur le ministre je
vous le dis c'est le moment oou jamais
de pouvoir suivre le rapport de la Cour
des comptes qui estime le besoin à 1,6
milliards pour pouvoir mettre des soins
palliatifs pour tous accessibles partout
on compte sur vous monsieur le ministre
pour prendre en charge ces gen jeux
plutôt qu'il ne soit réglé dans le seul
projet de loi de la fin de vie de la
ministre lebudau enfin concernant la
branche maladie des efforts ont été
faits ça a été dit sur la vaccination
sur la gratuité des moyens de
contraception et sur les préservatif sur
un dépistage du CMV au début de de la
grossesse mais le compte n'y est pas sur
un certain nombre de
nous l'avons déjà dit sur l'hôpital sur
les cliniques privées sur les épales 49
% de nos hôpitaux publics sont en
déficit 40 % de nos cliniques privées
sont en déficit 60 % de nos épades sont
en déficit et le PLFSS 2024 avec les 2
milliards qui manquent pour faire suivre
pour couvrir pardon les besoins de
l'inflation et les revalorisations de la
garde et de la permanence de nuit ne
suffiront pas alors on peut se
satisfaire effectivement de la
l'amendement des républicains sur la
plurianalité des ressources qui ont été
passées à 5 ans c'est un premier pas
mais on voit bien que pour l'instant il
manque l'essentiel à savoir une loi de
programmation de la santé pluriannuelle
les libéraux non plus ne s'y retrouvent
pas puisque il n'y aura aucun virage
ambulatoire aucun virage domiciliaire
sans u 40 % de nos infirmières
envisagent en libéral envisageent
d'arrêter leur profession à 5 ans alors
qu'on sait qu'elles sont complètement
écrasées par l'inflation puisqu'elles
ont une une non valorisation de leurs
actes depuis 2009 avec malheureusement
un taux un un plein d'essence qui ne
cesse d'augmenter et qui réduit leur
marge en permanence concernant enfin les
revalorisations des consultations le
1,50 € a bien a bien coupé les liens
avec la médecine libérale et nous
espérons que les renégociations vont
pouvoir revaloriser correctement les
prestations enfin nous restons quand
même extrêmement vigilant et nous sommes
pas convaincus par la nouvelle écriture
de l'article 9 sur l'argir Arco où il
n'est pas envisageable de faire la poche
des des des partenaires sociaux et c'est
vraiment une ligne rouge que nous
réaffirmons ce soir lors ces discussions
générales nous nous prenons acte de
votre renoncement de ne pas faire
d'économie sur la santé le dos de la
santé des Français en abandonnant les
800000 € de franchise par contre sur les
soins dentaires nous regrettons la
méthode 500000 € qui ont été transférés
sur les mutuels puisque des
remboursements depuis 1er octobre de
500000 € de frais dentaires sur les
mutuels ces mêmes mutuels qui sont
elles-mêmes à 57 % déficitaire qui ont
revalorisé leurs tarif de 5 % en 2023 et
qui vont probablement revaloriser leur
tarifs entre 8 à 10 % en 2024 3 millions
de Français sont sans mutuel donc il y
aura encore des renoncements de soins 50
% des Français ont déjà renoncé à des
soins d'encer du fait du fait de leur
coût enfin ce que je voudrais surtout
tout vous passez comme message monsieur
le ministre c'est un défaut d'écoute je
suis heureux que vous soyez saisi d'un
certain nombre de questions notamment
sur l'article 29 sur les dispositifs
médicaux à usage unique mais ça a été
bien laborieux pour pour arriver là nous
avons écrit plusieurs fois je vous ai
écrit en mai 2023 à votre prédécesseur
au ministre Béchu nous avons déposé une
proposition de résolution le 24 avril
2023 et l'Union européenne vous donnait
toute possibilité de pouvoir
effectivement permettre de pouvoir
réutiliser ces dispositifs médicaux il
est bien narant de voir tout ça arriver
que maintenant à l'article 29 sous forme
d'expérimentation alors que c'est des
mesures de bon sens qui ont des
avantages environnementaux et
économiques pour baisser l'empreunte
carbone qui vous le savez représente 8 %
dans le secteur de la santé enfin
Monsieur le Ministre le 29 octobre
prochain ça sera la journée mondiale des
accidents vasculaires cérébraux vous
savez que 140000 de nos concitoyens en
sont victimes chaque année et vous me
voyez arriver nous allons reparler sur
un sujet un peu technique de la
radiation en liste de la liste en sus
des liste des produits et prestations
remboursables puisque vous avez
dérboursé et sorti de cette liste les
guides de mesure des flux des réserves
coronire pour pouvoir traiter au mieux
par stetin les patients qui ont des
atteintes cardiaques coronaires et
surtout les cathétaires de reperfusion
pour trombosaspiration il n'y a pas de
réintégration financière dans le budget
des hôpitaux c'est 90 millions d'euros
de perte malgré un courrier à votre
prédécesseur malgré une question orale
au gouvernement en mars 2023 malgré
encore un courrier monsieur le ministre
en septembre 2023 malgré une table ronde
avec la DGOS avec la Direction de la
Sécurité sociale et malgré ce ce
courrier qui vous a encore été envoyé le
25 juillet par l'ensemble des
fédérations FHP FHF féap Unic cancer et
autres puisque malheureusement les
chimiothérapies en hôpital de jour sont
concerné on ne peut pas se résoudre
monsieur le ministre à ce que ces soins
soient déremboursés et que l'on puisse
créer du handicap par la non prise en
charge des accidents vasculaires qu'on
ne rembourse pas les chimiothérapies en
hôpital de jour donc vous le voyez un
certain nombre de mesures qui nous
l'ouvr encore ce soir les les les
l'espace de la négociation par le forme
sous la forme d'amendement nous espèr
que nous espérons que N allez pouvoir
revenir sur ces mesures de bon sens dans
l'intérêt de la santé de nos concitoyens
enfin dernier point concernant la fraude
qui est cher à notre groupe les
républicains nous sommes loin du compte
concernant les 8 milliards d'euros
annoncés par Gabriel Atal et surtout
nous avons aucun aucun aucun retour sur
la carte biométrique qui permettait
davantage de contrôle donc vous l'avez
compris euh beaucoup de choses sont à
sont encore à améliorer dans ce pfss
vous avez également euh compris qu'un
certain nombre de points seront évoqués
par thba Bazin concernant notamment la
branche famille les retraites et la
jarco en tout cas ce soir nous avons
voulu envoyer un message au gouvernement
en commission des Affaires social et
nous renverrons le même message en voton
contre ce PLFSS si tout ce que je vous
ai évoqué et si l'ensemble des
amendements que nous présenteront dans
les jours qui viennent ne sont pas
adoptés je vous
remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Nicolas turquis pour le groupe
démocrate
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2024 que nous examinons aujourd'hui est
BL ématique emblématique de l'exigence
de solidarité qui fait honneur de notre
pays emblématique de nos ambitions
élevées en matière de protection sociale
et de santé publique les différents
articles du projet de loi nous le
rappellent la large prise en charge des
principaux risques sociaux par la
collectivité est au cœur de notre pacte
républicain nous consacrons ainsi chaque
année un tiers de notre richesse
nationale au financement de la
protection sociale soit plus que tout
autre pays en Europe ou dans le monde
et quant à l'anupes vous parlez de honte
vous êtes dans l'incapacité de citer un
seul pays qui protège autant ses
concitoyens même si pour autant il reste
beaucoup à
faire notre responsabilité consiste dès
lors à préserver ce modèle social unique
en enrichissant et donc en votant le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour
2024 certes la Constitution contraint
l'examen du texte par le Parlement pour
autant cela n'équivaut pas un blanin
d'irresponsabilité pour l'opposition
comme les plus de 30 heures d'examen du
texte en commission ont parfois pu le
laisser penser
oui les contraintes budgétaires existent
oui ce projet de loi s'inscrit dans une
trajectoire de programmation des
finances publiques oui les comptes
publics se doivent de tendre vers
l'équilibre cette exigence de
responsabilité a animé le groupe
démocrate dans l'examen du texte en
commission vouloir financer de nouvelles
dépenses par des recettes équivalentes
ce n'est pas aller à la rencontre à
l'encontre de la solidarité c'est au
contraire de la rendre possible et
surtout
pérenne nous nous devons de veiller au
bon financement de notre sécurité
sociale pour être capable de faire face
au lendemain et pour établir un PLFSS
sérieux et responsable il faut le
replacer dans le contexte du
moment le contexte c'est d'abord celui
d'un système de santé qui porte encore
les stigmates de la crise sanitaire le
premier d'entre eux étant la fatigue et
la lassitude que ressentent encore trop
de personnel soignant
les conséquences de cette crise qui a
démontré à la fois les fragilités et la
résilience de notre système de santé se
traduisent également par des déficits
persistants 11,2 milliards d'euros cette
année dont nous ne pouvons pas nous
satisfaire l'essentiel de
l'accompagnement d'urgence de la crise
sanitaire est derrière nous désormais
avec seulement 200 millions d'euros de
dépenses provisionnées pour 2024 en
revanche le projet de loi poursuit la
dynamique d'augmentation salariale
initiée par le segéure de la santé avec
une enveloppe de 3,3 milliards d'euros
dédié à l'amélioration de la
rémunération des personnels médicaux et
paramédicaux les conséquences tirées de
la crise covid se retrouvent aussi dans
l'investissement renforcé en santé et
dans la lutte contre les pénuries de
médicaments le contexte de ce PLFSS
c'est aussi celui d'une forte inflation
d'un côté et d'une responsabilité
budgétaire de l'autre et dans ce cadre
contraint les pensions de retraite et
les prestations sociales se verront
Reval d'environ 5 % et l'ONDAM va
progresser de 3,2 % alors que
l'inflation est prévue à 2,6 en
2024 est-ce que nous mesurons la portée
exceptionnelle de ces efforts est-ce que
nous réalisons que l'ONDAM a progressé
de près de 64 milliards depuis 2017
est-ce que vous voulez voter contre ces
avancées hier la commission mixte
paritaire sur le projet de loi pour le
plein emploi à laquelle j'ai participé a
été conclusive il s'agit d'une étape
majeure pour tendre vers un taux de
chômage de 5 % d'ici 2027 et cette
adoption est en lien direct avec ce
PLFSS et les suivants dans la continuité
des réformes déjà engagées cette loi
contribuera à renforcer la pérenité de
notre modèle social à plusieurs égards
par de moindres dépenses d'une part
grâce à la capacité donnée à davantage
de personnes à trouver ou retrouver un
emploi mais aussi par des recettes plus
importantes plus il y a de personnes qui
travaillent plus les recettes fiscal et
social s'en trouve amélioré et donc
notre capacité à financer de nouvelles
avancées
sociales le groupe démocrate se félicite
donc d'une augmentation attendue de la
masse salariale du secteur privé de près
de 4 % en 2024 le plein emploi est bien
le meilleur moyen d'améliorer le
financement de notre protection
sociale mais ce projet de loi comporte
aussi plusieurs dispositions nécessaires
à la lutte contre la fraude l'action
sociale ne se réduit pas une cumulation
de nouvelles dépenses nous devons aussi
générer de nouvelles recettes et limiter
les dépenses indues la pérenité de notre
modèle de redistribution sociale
nécessite la confiance de nos
concitoyens dans l'équité du système
nous devons aborder sans tabou la
question des contrôles sur ce texte
comme sur les suivants et je laisserai à
ma collègue Anne Berg le soin de
développer tout à l'heure notre analyse
sur les dépenses prévues dans ce texte
je vous remercie je vous
remercie la Paro Estur pour le groupe
socialiste oui madame la
présidente madame messieurs les
ministres madame la Présidente de la
Commission madame la rapporteur générale
quand un ministre arrive à une
responsabilité il a j'en suis sûr bon
espoir d'imprimer sa marque sur les
chantiers en cours votre nomination tous
les trois je l'aurais dit si Aurore
berger était là mais tous les deux vous
le lui direz deveit également vous
permettre de traduire vos priorités dans
le PLFSS en cours de préparation hélas
trois fois hélas pour vous ce qui
restera de votre premier PLFSS c'est
qu'il aura été marqué par une première
depuis l'histoire des PLFSS être rejeté
en commission des affaires sociales et
je vous le dis tout de suite l'absence
de majorité ou la majorité relative ou
la minorité relative appelez ça comme
vous voulez n'explique pas tout ce en
commission pour moi signe aussi l'échec
de votre méthode d'abord mais aussi
l'épuisement de votre vision de la
sécurité sociale à rebour de ce que vous
nous avez dit désolé monsieur le
ministre dans vos propos introductifs en
rappelant l'origine de la sécurité
sociale citer em brise croisa et Pierre
laroc c'est bien rester fidèle à leur
exence c'est mieux la sécurité sociale
c'est chacun contribue son ses moyens et
reçoit selon ses besoins et c'est ce qui
manque j'y reviendrai singulièrement
dans votre PLFSS répondre aux besoins
des assurés sociaux des patients des
ayants droit et le rejet dernier élément
j'y reviendrai aussi nous dit aussi
peut-être et si on peut au moins ici
avoir cette réflexion que l'objet PLFSS
n'est plus du tout adapté aux enjeux de
la décision et des décisions que nous
devons prendre d'abord je veux vous dire
en étant attaché à la grandeur du débat
parlementaire et je le dis avec une une
gravité désabusé et avec la tristesse du
désœuvrement que malheureusement cette
année encore une épée de damoclesè
surpombe nos débats d'aujourd'hui et les
rang stéril inutile et 20 c'est le 493
devenu une sorte de fatalité inévitable
avec lui tout est joué à d'avance Dansel
quelques minutes ou plutôt dans quelques
heures la première ministre montera
cette estrade et PSALMO dira à nouveau
l'air qui commence à être familier à
l'ensemble des Français j'engage la
responsabilité de mon gouvernement sur
la première et la deuxème partie du
projet de loi de financement pour
2024 et votre projet de loi pour la le
budget de la Sécurité Sociale a beau
avoir été rejeté en commission des
affaires sociales bah en fait vous n'en
tireerez aucune conséquence pire vous
prétendez chercher des sujets de
consensus sans jamais faire de
concession ce qui admettez est un
exercice un petit peu étonnant
manifestant votre refus d'une démocratie
parlementaire vivante et consistante je
ne revient pas sur les épisodes qui ont
émaillé toute l'année
2022-223 on nous disait vous allez voir
ce que vous allez voir le Conseil
national de la refondation avec ses
volets sur la santé avec ses volets sur
le Bien Vieillir sur quoi tout cela a-il
déboucher de concret dans ces PLFSS je
ne reviens pas non plus sur l'initiative
politique d'ampleur que le Président de
la République avait souhaité convoquer à
la rentrée cela n'aura eu aucun effet
dans la séquence budgétaire que nous
traversons bref à coup d'opération de
communication vous plongez la France
dans une initiative politique d'ampleur
improvisée en continu vous n'arrêtez pas
de répéter aussi que vous voulez trouver
des compromis de projets ou des
majorités de projets mais dans les faits
vous faites exactement le contraire l'an
dernier alors euh vous vous étiez avec
la minorité présidentielle au moins
astreint à organiser des groupes
transpartisans au niveau de la
Commission mission des affaires sociales
les débouchés avaient été limité mais ce
format avait le mérite d'exister cette
année c'est fini vous ne faites même
plus semblant pas plus que je me
rappelle la promesse de votre
prédécesseur de dire nous travaillerons
très en amont au PLFSS je vous ai
entendu prochain je vous ai entendu nous
le dire à nouveau cher Aurélien Rousseau
bien écoutez nous vérifierons si nous
sommes capables de travailler non pas
qu' jour ou 3 semaines auparavant comme
avec vos comptes de séure où d'une
certaine manière vous nous présentiez
les arbitrages déjà réalisé ce n'est pas
comme cela que vous allez créer des
majorités de projets et même quand nous
tentons de jouer le jeu de la
coconstruction bien vous rejetez en bloc
ça me permet à cet instant et je le dis
devant le ministre casaznav de revenir
sur une petite entourloupe quand vous
nous indiquez que c'est sur la base du
rapport de Marc ferci et de Jérôme GED
que vous allez prendre des amendements
de gel des seuils de calcul des 25 et 35
ce n'était pas la conclusion à laquelle
nous étions arrivés la conclusion à
laquelle nous étions arrivés c'est que
les exonérations de cotisation sociale
peuvent être questionné elles doivent
l'être que de manière certaine entre 2,5
et 3,5 SMIC elles n'ont aucun impact
aucun impact sur l'emploi et sur la
compétitivité et nous proposions
purement et simplement de les supprimer
c'était tellement partagé que j'avais
déposé un amendement avec quelqu'un de
chez vous avec sa choulier président de
la commission des lois et membre de la
majorité bah malgré cela il est pas
retenu le consensus coproduit par des
parlementaires ne retient pas votre
attention je pourrais vous citer aussi
le travail fait sur les déserts médicaux
dans le cadre du groupe de travail
transpartisan porté par mon collègue
Guillaume Garot je pourrais vous parler
aussi de la volonté affichée sur tous
les bancs de l'hémicycle de travailler
ensemble à une loi de programmation sur
le grand âge à musclé j'y reviendrai le
travail sur ce sujet au contraire chaque
initiative est Brié bridée
muselée cadenacé et au final nous nous
retrouvons avec des amendements que nous
avons pu réussir à faire voter en
commission mais dont nous savons qu'ils
vont passer à la roulette du 493 où
quelque part on ne sais où on ira
piocher tel ou tel amendement pour
retenir je ne sais pas par exemple si
ceux que j'ai avec d'autres pu
contribuer à faire voter pour
sanctionner de manière plus efficace les
professionnels de santé fraudur en
procédant systématiquement et totalement
au remboursement des exonérations de
cotisation sociale je ne sais pas au
moment où je vous parle si vous le
retiendrait dans le fameux
493 et pourtant je le dis avec beaucoup
de franchises euh nous reconnaissons que
ce projet comporte des avancées comme à
chaque fois que nous saluons encore
heureux serais-je tenté de dire le souci
c'est que systématiquement elle s'arrête
au milieu du gay évidemment la gratuité
des préservatifs et des protections
menstruelles pour les moins de 26 ans
c'est très bien mais bigre pourquoi
s'arrêter à 26 ans je pense aussi au
lancement de la campagne nationale de
vaccination contre le papiomarie virus
dès la classe de 5e de 5e un/ers des
jeunes hommes de plus de 15 ans sont
porteurs d'un papilloma virirus et
environ et environ 20 % sont atteints
d'un type de H PV qui pourrait engendrer
un cancer il y a urgence et vous avez
pris à sa juste mesure le dossier mais
pourquoi une minorité et je sais que ce
cet angle mort vous préoccupe monsieur
le ministre une minorité de collèges
privés freine des cas de fer pour le
déploiement pourquoi ne pas avoir
déployé la réalisation de campagne hors
les mur de l'école dans les clubs
sportifs dans les MJC et d'essayer
d'élargir j'espère que vous pourrez
reprendre cette proposition nous saluons
aussi enfin le début de commencement de
l'amorce d'un début de la fusion des
sections soins et dépendances le
problème
le problème c'est que cette mesure
réclamée par tous les acteurs elle était
dans le rapport de Dominique Libau mais
en choisissant l'adhésion volontaire des
conseils départementaux il y a un risque
d'une réforme à minima et surtout d'un
financement des épades à deux vitesses
qui va complexifier la vie des
opérateurs et notamment de ceux qui
agissent à l'échelle nationale vous
avancez aussi sur la fameuse
tarification à l'activité des hôpitaux
pour les activités de médecine de
chirurgie d'obscétrique enfin Emmanuel
Macron c'était en non au vux au
personnel de santé avait indiqué qu'il
sétait tromper la fois précédente où il
avait dit on va le faire on va le faire
de manière progressive et donc là il
avait de manière très péremptoire
indiqué que on allait voir ce qu'on
allait voir dès le prochain PLFSS les
choses allaient changer radicalement
mais votre réforme elle est inaboutie
nulle part la part de la T2A n'y est
plafonnée et ce PLFSS n'indique même pas
de taux cible à atteindre pour financer
effectivement autrement l'hôpital alors
contrairement à ce que vous allez nous
raconter ce 493 n'était pas inévitable
vous auriez pu voir vous auriez pu
écouter vous auriez pu coconstruire mais
comme d'habitude vous n'en avez rien
fait vous avez dit clairement à nous et
à travers nous aux soignants aux
patients circuler il y a rien à voir
parce que ce PLFSS et c'est son drame
euh originel ne répond pas aux urgences
sociales et sanitaires qui frappent les
Français parce que la seule boussole qui
vous guide c'est celle d'une rigueur
budgétaire alors on peut jouer sur les
mots peut-être pas austérité mais à
minima euh rigueur budgétaire et ce
PLFSS ne permet pas de construire une
politique de santé ni une politique du
grand âge consistante comme l'année
dernière vous avez écouté mais vous
n'avez pas entendu vous avez vu mais
vous n'avez pas regardé l'année dernière
lors du débat rappelez-vous des plfs du
PLFSS 2023 nous vous avions alerté au
diapason des fédérations et de
l'ensemble des acteurs du secteur
l'ondame que vous proposiez n'était pas
à la hauteur d'une inflation que nous
savions déjà massive laissant les
professionnels de santé dans le flou
toute l'année et vous avez au gré euh
des euh rectifications corrigé
significativement euh l'ONDAM
hospitalier
100,7 milliards en loi de financement
initial il est passé en 101,3 milliards
en avril dernier pour atteindre 102,5
milliards d'euros aujourd'hui c'est
exactement les amendements que nous vous
proposions l'année dernière en vous
disant dès le début mettez l'argent
nécessaire aurez de la visibilité et ne
mettez pas dans des situations
pérriilleuse l'ensemble des acteurs vous
êtes sur une trajectoire budgétaire en
perdition et c'est extrêmement
problématique nous vous le redisons avec
solennité à nouveau avec un N d'â
inférieure à l'inflation parce que la
réalité c'est que l'inflation ne sera
pas celle que vous escomtez et les
projections que vous indiquez vous allez
continuer à fragiliser considérablement
les établissements et les services je
veux reciter la FHF je vois Frédéric
Valtou qui est présent et je le redis
que c'est souvent un lieu d'expertise
quand elle nous dit qu'il faudrait
rajouter au moins 2,8 milliards d'euros
pour faire face à la crise que nous
traversons quand elle nous dit qu'il
manque 1,9 milliard d'euros pour l'ONDAM
hospitalier quand elle nous dit qu'il
manque 500 million d'euros pour l'ONDAM
médico-social alors nous sommes au
devant de grandes difficultés sur le
grand âge vous avez annoncé en 2022
votre volonté de créer 50000 postes en
épad c'était une promesse de campagne
d'Emmanuel Macron où en sommes-nous où
en sommes-nous vous en avez budgeté 3000
en 203 6000 en 2024 en 2 ans vous aurez
fait 9000 sur les 50000 et d'ors et déjà
on commence à nous préparer en disant ce
sera à l'horizon 2030 et puis à
l'horizon 2027 c'est à peine 1,2
équivalent temps plein ETP créé dans
chacun des 7000 épades de France c'est
pas ça qui va changer ni l'attractivité
des métiers ni les conditions de travail
pour l'ensemble des salariés ni les
conditions d'accueil pour les personnes
pour les personnes âgées et donc nous
vous alertons vous ne nous aurez pas
avec la petite loi grand âge dite PPL
bien vieillir retenez la demande des
parles parlementaire unanime ils ont
voté ici à l'unanimité la demande pour
une loi de programmation grand âge en
avril et depuis cette date si Aurore
berger avait était là j'aurais espéré
qu'elle puisse l'entendre et pas une
seule expression d'un ministre ou de la
première ministre pour dire nous avons
entendu la demande unanime des
parlementaires il y aura une loi de
programmation grand âge j'y reviendrai
dans un instant la détresse elle est
pourtant là elle est visible il y a
urgence les professionnels de santé je
vous recite l'article la tribune dans Le
Monde le 10 octobre dernier ù 1200
soignants nous disent cette chose
terrible monsieur le ministre dorénavant
nous soignants sommes contraints en
toutes circonstances de trier les
patient de vous trier pire parfois nous
n'arrivons même plus à vous prioriser
par ordre de gravité voilà où nous en
sommes voilà où où en sont les centres
hospitaliers je lis la presse
quotidienne régionale dans le populaire
du centre en Haut- de Vienne Isabelle
explique il y a des jours où presque la
moitié de mes collègues sont en arrêt
tellement ils sont épuisés dans le
Journal du Centre dans la Nièvre des
équipes en sous effectif permanent des
médicaments mal distribués ou non donnés
des toilettes non réalisées des journées
sans infirmière ou avec un seul pour 80
résidents la situation elle est
dramatique le drame de votre PLFSS c'est
que la réponse que vous apportez c'est
celle de l'injustice et de l'austérité
l'injustice c'est d'augmenter les impôts
sur la maladie avec l'augmentation de la
participation forfaitaire les fameuses
franchises et je le dis au moment où
nous parlons aucune clarification
monsieur le ministre nous ne savons pas
si elles seront décidées ou pas décidées
pour nous c'est absolument insupportable
l'injustice c'est de s'en prendre aux
personnes qui recourent au transport
sanitair quand elle n'accepte pas les
transports partagés l'injustice toujours
c'est quand vous financez votre réforme
des retraites en déshabillant AG Carco
pour habiller votre réforme et là au
moment où on parle avec l'article 9 vous
pouvez encore le faire donc est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire clairement ça
n'aura pas lieu en aucun cas il n'y aura
cette ponction voilà les éléments qui
manquent considérablement à la
transparence de nos débats et à la
clarté de ce que nous pouvons faire
pourtant il y a besoin de opposition
alternative audacieuse forte et féconde
et le point de départ c'est de pas c'est
de gouverner par les besoins c'est ça
qui est essentiel aujourd'hui nous
l'avons dit redit et redit alors au
moment de conclure je veux vous dire que
mon humeur est à la frustration la
frustration parce que parce que ce texte
ne répond pas aux urgences l'ambition
d'un PLFSS c'est de repousser sans cesse
les frontières de la solidarité et vous
vous nous proposez d'une certaine
manière le contraire et comme je vous le
disais ce PLFSS n'est plus le bon outil
pour programmer pour anticiper il nous
faudrait une loi de programmation et
d'orientation sanitaire sur 5 ans qui
intégrerait une stratégie nationale de
santé et des objectifs de santé publi
qui n'existent pas aujourd'hui et la
même chose pour une loi de programmation
sur le grand âge car bon sang on est
capable dans ce pays de faire des lois
de programmation pour nos armées pour la
police pour la justice et le social
c'est aussi regalien que la que la
défense et pour ça il faut de la
transparence de la délibération
collective de la démocratie sanitaire je
vous lis un auteur que j'ai lu avec
plaisir une société démocratique ne peut
sortir plus grande d'une crise de cette
ampleur il parlait du covid qu'en étant
convaincu que la transparence et le
partage des réussites comme des échecs
sont les conditions de notre capacité
collective à faire face la transparence
cela imposera aussi d'inventer une forme
de partage et de délibération citoyenne
sur la manière d'assurer la santé de la
population sur la place du soin sur
celle de la prévention sur la place des
enjeux financiers comme sur celle
prignante de la démographie des
professionnels de santé il faut en
prendre le risque Aurélien Rousseau
c'est la conclusion de votre joli livre
la blessure et le rebond c'est bien
dommage que devenu ministre cher
Aurélien Rousseau vous n'ayez pas couru
ce risque vous nous auriez trouvé à vos
côté je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Frédéric Valtou pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
horizon
messieurs les messieurs les ministres
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales madame la
rapporteur générale Mesdames et
Messieurs chers
collègues avec le groupe horizon nous
partageons pleinement les objectifs
assignés à ce
PLFSS c'est c'est un scoop assurer la
pérennité et la modernisation de notre
modèle de protection sociale adapter nos
politiques sanitaires et sociales autant
que possible au besoins tout en
organisant la sortie de plusieurs années
de crise sanitaire et donc en diminuant
notre déficit cite tenir cet objectif
sans fragiliser plus encore un système
de santé qui est déjà malade l'exercice
est difficile lorsqu'on sait bien sûr
que l'objectif des dépenses pour 2024
reste contraint par celui de 2023 nous
savons tous ici que cette année les
établissements de santé qu' soi public
ou privé vont voir leur compte se
dégrader le déficit s'accroîtra pour les
hôpitaux et les marges de rentabilité se
diminueront sérieusement pour les
cliniques commerciales alors ce constat
il a été fait il a ça a été abondamment
cité à cette tribune par l'ensemble des
fédérations don celle que j'ai eu
l'honneur de présider pendant de de
longues années et c'est bien normal de
dire quel est effectivement l'objectif
souhaité je rappelle que l'AM c'est un
objectif que nous parlons de l'année 202
24 et que je ne connais pas un seul
gouvernement qui n'est pas rectifié en
cours d'année en fonction de la réalité
de de l'activité au fil de l'année qui
n'est pas rectifié cet objectif de de
dépense pour accompagner les
établissements les établissements de
santé moi je voudrais dire deux choses
la première c'est que jamais aucun
gouvernement depuis t ceux ceux qui se
sont succédés depuis 2017 n'ont jamais
autant accompagné l'hôpital alors
peut-être on peut mettre ça sur le dos
effectivement de la crise sanitaire qui
a peut-être fait prendre conscience que
l'hôpital nécessitait un remède de
cheval mais quand on voit le montant
d'investissement quand on voit le Ségure
de la santé et donc l'effort qui a été
fait les 9 milliards d'euros versés pour
les salaires et je ne parle que de là de
de l'hôpital ce sont des efforts
qu'aucun gouvernement par le passé et on
peut remonter loin dans le temps aucun
gouvernement n'avait n'avait fait alors
évidemment ça n'est peut-être pas assez
mais je tiens à à le dire la deuxième
chose qu'il faut dire c'est
qu'effectivement pour sortir notre
système de santé des de la des des des
des tensions financières que l'on que
que l'on évoque et que l'on connaît et
bien il faudra engager des
transformations profondes nécessaire et
ce que souhaite d'ailleurs le président
de la République et ce qu'entâ ce PLFSS
j'y reviendrai dans dans quelques
minutes parce que la crise est profonde
et la crise d'attractivité des métiers
du soin elle est aussi très preignante
3 ans et demi après le premier
confinement nous devons tenir un
discours de vérité nous devons un
discours de vérité pour les Français
nous devons tourner le dos quoi qu'il en
coûte quelle que soit la douleur et la
difficulté que cela représente nous
avons démontré lors de la crise notre
capacité à mobiliser nos ressources pour
protéger la nation quand elle en avait
besoin mais nous ne pouvons plus
dépenser sans compter je pense que tout
le monde le comprend à la fois pour la
bonne santé de notre économie mais aussi
pour la pérennité de ce système de
protection sociale auquel nous de nous
nous que nous souhaitons tous nous
devons maîtriser nos déficits et celui
de la sécurité sociale bien sûr ne fait
pas exception grâce à la politique menée
par le gouvernement après des déficits
historiques il faut se rappeler les
chiffres 40 milliards de déficit en 2020
le solde des régimes obligatoires de
base et du fond de solidarité vieillesse
c'est nettement redressé sous l'effet
bien sûr de la reprise économique et des
créations d'emplois puisque en 2024 ce
déficit persisterait à plus de 11
milliards d'euros bien loin des 40
milliards d'euros de 2020 en tant que
législateur il en va de notre
responsabilité de maintenir les
financements nécessaires de notre
protection sociale et la préserver pour
nos enfants c'est ce que fait le
gouvernement et cette majorité en 2024
rappelons aussi quelques chiffres nous
finançons 105 milliards d'euros pour
l'hôpital nous finançons 254 milliards
d'euros pour londam nous finançons 295
milliards d'euros pour l'assurance
vieillesse nous finançons 58 milliards
d'euros pour nos politiques familiales
tous ces budgets sont en augmentation
ces budgets sont sin inédit et je redis
notre majorité présidentielle n'a pas à
rougir des chiffres qui sont là ces
budgets ce sont la revalorisation des
pensions de retraite de plus de 5 % ce
sont plus de 3 milliards d'euros de
risation de revalorisation des pour les
personnels sanitaires médicau-sociaux et
pour la petite enfance il tient aussi de
notre responsabilité en parallèle de
maîtriser les dépenses quand elles
peuvent l'être avec des économies
raisonnées garantissant l'équilibre
global du système tout tout en
maintenant les droits des Français notre
boussole doit être la suivante chaque
euro des Français doit être dépensé de
façon juste et efficace à à ce titre
nous soutenons l'objectif de 3,5
milliards d'euros d'économie porté par
ce budget elle s'accompagne de mesures
de responsabilisation des acteurs du
système de santé et des mesures de lutte
contre la fraude sociale impératif
d'équité et de justice pour l'ensemble
des assuré je pense par exemple à la
très forte dynamique des dépenses
d'indemnité jour journalière maladie
observé ces dernières années qui n'est
que partiellement lié à l'amélioration
du marché de l'emploi et à
l'augmentation des des salaires il
convient de veiller à la pertinence des
dépenses des arrêts maladies en
renforçant les modalités de contrôle
tant des prescripteurs que des assurés
pour une finée éviter tout arrêt de
travail qui ne serait pas ou plus
médicalement justifié ce p ce PLFSS le
prévoit et je m'en félicite néanmoins
année après année ces objectifs de
dépenses que nous nous fixons s'ils sont
nécessaires rendent difficiles les
réformes de fond elles aussi nécessaires
pour rétablir les comptes à long terme
et en finir avec et ne pas retomber dans
la politique du rabot cher au quinquenat
d'avant 2017 il faut que parallèlement
au maintien du Cap budgétaire que nous
nous sommes fixés nous réfléchissions à
des réformes de structure au premier
rang desquels je pense à la réforme du
système de financement en effet nos
règles de financement sont daté près de
30 ans après la création Lam il est
temps de remettre à place la constru u
en enveloppe fermée mais aussi d'engager
une vraie pluré annualité qui donne de
la perspective aux acteurs de santé il
faut également mieux objectiver les
dépenses inutiles pour mieux les
combattre je veux ici rappeler qu'en
septembre 2018 déjà le président de la
République avait rappelé en lançant ma
réforme ma santé 2022 pardon que 30 %
des dépenses de santé étaient sans doute
des dépenses inutiles indues ou non
pertinentes et qu'une régulation plus
ferme était nécessaire je partage ce
constat depuis longtemps nous savons que
le salut de notre système de santé à
l'heure d'une nécessaire maîtrise des
comptes publics pour assurer sa
pérennité passe par la priorité à
s'attaquer aux rentes au revenus faciles
afin de se concentrer sur ce qui sert
réellement la la santé des Français par
ailleurs le modèle de financement
l'activité perçu comme l'alpha et
l'oméga du financement du système
hospitalier et des soins de ville a
abouti à des excès cela vaut autant à
l'hôpital où la tarification à
l'activité représente la moitié des
financements que dans le secteur privé
où sa part est beaucoup plus élevée ce
PLFSS amorce une évolution mais sans
doute il revient d'être plus audacieux
plus audacieux dans le PLF SS 2025 pour
prolonger les les les réformes qui sont
initiées car la crise pote son nez la
crise de l'offre publique elle a été
évoquée mais aussi la crise de la
médecine de ville au moment où s'ouvre
des négociations avec les médecins de
ville il faut rappeler que la la
garantie qu'apporte notre système de
santé doit permettre à que chacun
participe à l'effort national servent
l'intérêt qu'attendent les Français et
que le le sujet n'est pas uniquement AFF
faaire d'argent de budget et de meilleur
accompagnement des acteurs des acteurs
privés mais aussi une affaire de donnant
donnant pour l'État qu'il puisse aussi
obtenir IR que globalement ce système se
réforme et que les acteurs changent dans
leurs habitudes au quotidien c'est
l'objet très modestement de la
proposition de loi que j'ai eu l'honneur
de proposer à l'Assemblée nationale qui
a été adopté qui est en ce moment en
discussion au Sénat et qui doit
permettre de faire bouger les lignes
dans les territoires pour que ensemble
les acteurs prennent mieux en main plus
en main de manière plus responsable et
collective la question de l'accès aux
soins des des Français je veux terminer
en citant quelques avancées qui que que
recelle ce PLF F SS qui sont importantes
aussi pour nos concitoyens je souhaite
souligner le volet prévention qu'il y a
dans ce PLFSS qui concrétise de nombreux
engagements de ce gouvernement mais
aussi de nombreuses aspirations portées
par la majorité présidentielle mais
aussi par de nombreux groupes ici dans
cette assemblée je pense bien sûr à la
gratuité des préservatifs pour les
jeunes ça a été rappelé ou le
déploiement d'une campagne de
vaccination ambitieuse contre le
papiomavirus pour enchir ce texte notre
groupe a fait des propositions là aussi
pour améliorer et pousser plus loin les
log de transparence de santé publique et
de justice sociale je veux sans être
trop long évoquer la politique de
prévention à travers la promotion
l'activité physique et sportive qui a
été décrété par le Président de la
République grande cause nationale pour
rembourser ce qu'on appelle le sport par
ordonnance et donc mieux accompagner
certaines affections longue durées comme
le cancer ou le diabète nous proposons
de créer un parcours de soins aussi
spécifique pour les femmes souffrant de
postpartom une maladie qui touche 10 à
20 % des nouvelles mères c'est une
proposition constructive euh peu
onéreuse monsieur le ministre des
comptes publics et qui je pense va dans
le sens euh du virage vers la prévention
que l'on souhaite tous voir opérer à
notre système de de santé pour
l'organisation des soins nous souhaitons
généraliser la signature de certificat
de décès par les infirmiers aujourd'hui
expérimentés dans certains territoires
il est temps là aussi de libérer un un
les de libérer du temps aux médecins de
les de permettre la délégation de tâche
de manière là aussi à rendre plus F plus
fluide pardon la réponse euh du corps
médical aux besoins des Français la
limitation au médecins est une vraie
situation de blocage dans les
territoires et les maires savent
exactement quoi je fais bien sûr
référence enfin je tiens à dénoncer
l'attitude des oppositions à laquelle
nous avons assisté la semaine dernière
et qui a conduit au rejet de ce texte à
la suppression de nombreux articles
fixant les objectifs de dépenses pour
l'année prochaine et certains articles
comportant même d'ailleurs des
propositions qui étaient avancées par
ces mêmes oppositions c'est la première
fois depuis la création des lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale en
1996 que l'Assemblée nationale N nadopte
pas en commission le PLFSS au-delà
au-delà effectivement du fond il faut il
faut y voir effectivement un jeu de
posture parce que refuser un budget qui
comporte un certain nombre d'avancées
proposé par les oppositions elles-mêmes
est un nonsens que les Français ne
comprennent pas je dire le monde n'est
pas parfait ce PLFSS est sans doute à
discuter comme tous les textes ils sont
à discuter mais ils comportte de vraies
avancées pour le bienfait des Français
et laavoir refuser de cette manière
c'est tourner le dos justement à la
démocratie merci
beaucoup je vous remerci
la parole est à Madame cyielle châelin
pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame la Présidente
messieurs les ministres madame la
rapporteur chers collègues disonsli
clairement ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale n'a
pas de majorité il a été rejeté en
commission et il serait rejeté s'il
était soumis au vote dans cet hémicycle
les outils de la Constitution vous
permettront de l'imposer mais dans ces
cas-là vous porterez seul la
responsabilité d'un cadrage budgétaire
endessà des besoins des Français et des
Françaises vous porterez seul la
responsabilité d'une politique qui
fragilise notre modèle social et notre
santé publique la première erreur
commise par ce gouvernement est de s
enfermé dans une impasse idéologique
d'un côté vous multipliez les
dispositifs d'exonération d'impôt les
baisses de cotisation sociales ce sont
18 milliards de baisses d'impôt de
production depuis qu'Emmanuel Macron est
à la tête de l'État et de l'autre vous
refusez d'examiner de nouvelles pistes
de financement qui permettrai de mieux
répartir les richesses pas de recette
pas de dépenses finalement la politique
de ce projet de loi c'est le statut quo
c'est regarder notre système de santé se
dégrader peu à peu c'est une action
sociale elle était inscrite déjà dans la
loi de programmation des finances
publiques elle-même imposée par 493
après deux échecs au sein de cette
Assemblée une loi de programmation des
finances publiques qui n'est rien
d'autre qu'une feuille de route de
l'austérité programmée du service public
que devront subir tous les Français et
les Françaises effectivement la loi de
programmation contonne jusqu'en 2027
l'ensemble des dépenses de soins et
d'accompagnement soit à 2 à 22 % du PIB
ni l'ondame ni le sousondame n'échappe à
ce mécanisme avec cette trajectoire vous
vous êtes vous-même rendu impuissant et
c'est les Français et les Françaises qui
payeront l'impact de ce renoncement la
deuxième erreur commise par ce
gouvernement est finalement d'avoir
confondu ce projet de loi dont
l'objectif normalement est de définir
les objectifs de dépenses en un outil de
maîtrise des dépenses sociales et de
santé déterminer l'équilibre du régime
ne veut pas dire maîtriser les défenses
mais s'assurer que les recettes soient
suffisantes pour pour assurer les
dépenses dans votre vision du monde les
dépenses finalement doivent se soumettre
à vos baisses d'impôt successives dans
notre vision du monde la la sécurité
sociale est au cœur de notre contrat
social mais non sinon vous seriez bien
nous c'est au cœur de notre contrat
social parce que pour vous en fait vous
baissez les impôts d'abord vous
réfléchissez ensuite à quel objectif
vous voulez donner nous on dit regardons
les besoins et nous avons besoin surtout
de concrétiser la promesse qu'en chaque
enfant chaque femme chaque homme doit
avoir une vie digne c'est ça notre
objectif notre seul objectif c'est de
pouvoir protéger les Français leur
garantir qu'ils auront accès à une santé
à une santé publique à une santé
gratuite à une santé de
qualité mais finalement vous ne
légiférez pas pour protéger les Français
vous légiférez pour maîtriser les
dépenses publiques alors la maîtrise des
dépenses publique nous impose de années
de travail supplémentaires alors la
finance maîtrise la finance publique
finalement demande de faire la chasse
aux arrêts maladies alors la maîtrise de
la dépense publique nécessite de
pressurer nos services publics
finalement vous affaiblissez et vous
réduisez àau de chararmin le service
public c'est toute notre patrimoine
commun que vous réduisez enfin la
troisème erreur de ce gouvernement est
de penser que notre système de santé
tient droit quoi qu'il en coûte oui le
personnel soignant est remarquable oui
il donne bien plus que nous le faisons
peut-être tous aujourd'hui ils font ils
donnent en fait tout ce qu'ils ont et
parfois bien au-delà mais un jour à
force de tirer sur la corde ça
craque les urgences ferment les
soignants font des burnout des
opérations sont sont déprogrammées en
iser en grenobble c'est des centaines
d'opérations pédiatriques qui ont été
déprogrammées les en fait les passtients
trinqu les soignants trinqu tout le
monde était Soré c'est ça la réalité et
c'est qu'à un moment oui ça ne tiendra
plus parce qu'en fait ce qui paraît
technique cette idée d'avoir des
objectifs de dépenses de l'assurance
maladie c'estàdire ce qu'on appelle l'AM
quon le sous-évalue qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire concrètement dans les services
et dans les hôpitaux ça veut dire qu'on
rere tout ça veut dire qu'on resserre
les dépenses ça veut dire qu'on
rationalise les soins ça veut dire qu'on
demande plus de productivité au
personnel comme si on pouvait parler de
productivité quand on s'agit du soin de
l'autre et on modère la masse salariale
c'est augmenté
de l'ONDAM elle existe mais elle est
largement insuffisante la Fédération
Hospitalière demande plus de milliards
pour l'ONDAM hospitalière plus 700
millions pour l'endam des personnes
jasées plus 100 millions pour l'endam
des personnes en situation de handicap
alors ce qu'on vous dit c'est que oui
c'est possible et nous avons proposer de
nombreuses pistes de financement qui
permettent de répondre à ces besoins
vous les retrouverez dans le débat qu'on
aura pas eu et je veux juste finir que
si notre système de de soins craque il
n'y aura qu'un seul responsable et
monieur le gouvernement ça sera
bon
la parole est à Monsieur Pierre
daréville pour le groupe Gauche
démocrate et
[Applaudissements]
républicaine
merci madame la Présidente
messieurs les ministres chers et chers
collègues au capitaine mon
capitaine
[Applaudissements]
carpédiè cuœille le jour présent j'ai
conscience de la fugacité de ce moment
de sa rareté autant que de son étrangeté
nous ne savons pas encore à quel instant
le fil se brisera à quel instant l'épée
tombera à quel instant son tranchant
arrêtera nos débats à quel instant vous
imposerez votre choix c'est toute la
magie du suspense pour ce qu'il en reste
car les feuilles mortes se ramassent à
l'appel comme les 493
aussi d'ailleurs certains d'entre nous
ont dit que celui qui vient nous
l'aurions bien mérité ah si la
commission des affaires sociales avait
sagement adopté cet objectif national de
dépenses d'assurance maladie inquiétant
et ce budget indigeent mais non fait
inédit elle a rejeté votre projet une
première depuis la création des lois de
financement en 1996 et cela devrait vous
obliger à réfléchir et à changer
d'orientation à bouger le cadre et ce
que j'ai entendu dénoncer encore il y a
quelques instants c'est tout simplement
en réalité que nous sommes en désaccord
que peut-on dire de ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
d'abord que c'est le même que le
précédent en pire et le précédent
n'était déjà pas terrible non seulement
il nétait pas terrible mais il a été
carrément marqué au fer rouge par la loi
rectificative de casse du droit à la
retraite qui a été imposé par un 493 à
un pays qui n'en voulait pas ce projet
de loi de financement porte lesestigmate
des premières conséquences ingrates de
cette loi indigne et c'est la première
raison pour laquelle il provoque notre
colère avec au passage des dispositions
qui ne tiennent pas debout concernant le
régime spécial des électriciens et
gaziers ensuite il prévoit de continuer
les exonérations massives de cotisation
sociale en commission un amendement a
été adopté par la majorité qui annule
une exonération sur les bons salaires et
qui supprime pour le même montant le peu
qui restait sur les bas salaires vous
êtes en réalité accro aux exos et vous
encouragez les bas salaires alors même
que vous êtes si peu enclin à augmenter
le salaire net vous ne pouvez pas vous
empêcher de raboter le salaire brut de
délégitimer la cotisation qui est
pourtant le fondement de notre
protection sociale cette année encore
2,5 milliards d'exonérations de
cotisation sur les heures
supplémentaires ne seront pas compensé
la sécurité sociale ne doit pas être la
variable d'ajustement des politiques
économiques il faut arrêter de la
sous-financer et investir l'argent de la
compensation dans la fonction publique
et les services publics qui sont en
crise en conséquence votre budget
prévoit une nouvelle compression des
dépenses de santé ces objectifs 3,2 sont
en dessous de l'augmentation
tendantielle voilà des années et des
années que vous demandez des économies à
l'hôpital public qui n'en finit pas de
s'enfoncer dans la crise j'étais à Alès
il y a quelques jours monsieur le
ministre les urgences fonctionnaient en
mode régulation et les revendications
ressemblaient à celles que je rencontre
chez moi vous avez le bonjour du pays la
semaine dernière à Martigue se tenait un
rassemblement pour défendre l'hôpital
public comme il s'en tient un peu
partout dans le pays et lorsqu'ils ont
appris que votre projet de budget avait
été rejeté en commission une grande
clameur a retenti votre budget avait
déjà été rejeté par le Conseil de la
Caisse nationale d'assurance maladie
parce que je cite il n'apporte pas de
réponse structurelle il avait été
fortement critiqué par la Fédération
hospitalière de France qui estime le
plancher à 3 milliards supplémentaires
pour boucler 2023 et à 5 milliards pour
2024 et vous tracez pour les années qui
viennent une trajectoire impossible elle
est encore moins ambitieuse ce n'est pas
sérieux ce n'est pas à la hauteur ce
n'est pas responsable en fait il n'y a
que vous qui vous le qui le trouvait bon
ce budget et encore ce n'est même pas
sûr mais vous le défendez l'un essaie de
nous vendre du rêve l'autre nous dit
faut pas rêver répétant à la façon de
magrit ceci n'est pas de l'austérité et
au final les comptes de Ségure ce sera
les malheurs de Sophie l'hôpital public
a besoin d'un nouveau souffle de
perspectiv d'un grand plan d'embauche et
de déprécarisation d'ouverture de
négociation salarial de la radiologie et
la psychiatrie en passant par les soins
palliatifs la crise est là ne laissons
pas dépérir la radiologie hospitalière
qui est un de ces atouts importants pour
faire face ne laissons pas dégringoler
encore la psychiatrie dans une société
où l'humain est soumis à rue d'épreuve
un an pour un rendez-vous dans un centre
médico-psychologique c'est tout
simplement inacceptable au lieu de vous
entêter dans un dispositif mon parcours
psy qui est un échec embaucher des
psychologues à l'hôpital et dans la
fonction publique ne laissons pas dans
l'ombre non plus la question essentielle
des soins palliatifs qui devrait être un
droit et qui ne le sont pas parce que
depuis des années et des années on s'est
refusé à y mettre réellement les moyens
même la Cour des comptes le dit ce
budget ne propose rien à la matière
quant aux besoins de rénovation et de
construction ils seront au moins bien
prise en compte encore avec une
réduction programmée de l'enveloppe
c'est d'autant plus problématique que la
sortie annoncée de la tarification à
l'acte n'aura pas lieu les mesurettes
que vous proposez vont nous faire passer
de 56 % à 49 % pour la médecine
chirurgie obstétrique en 2026 le volume
de soins n'est toujours pas revenu à son
niveau d'avant covid en revanche même
dans les hôpitaux qui qui ont accru leur
volume d'activité comme celui de martig
au prix d'efforts considérabl le déficit
est toujours au rendez-vous de toute
évidence il faudrait également se donner
les moyens d'agir sur les déserts
médicaux il faudrait déclencher un plan
de soutien et de développement des
centres de santé à but non lucratif il
faudrait également s'attaquer avec
méthode au défi du médicament l'un des
vecteurs de la marchandisation et de la
financiarisation de la santé alors que
les pénuries n'en n'en finissent pas
vous augmentez encore les marges des
grands laboratoire et vous refusez de
mettre en chantier la construction d'un
pôle public du médicament nous en
aurions pourtant bien besoin pour faire
face au défis des pénuries mais aussi à
celui des médicaments biologiques dont
la fabrication devrait s'appuyer sur les
outils publics et sur une relance
ambieuse de la dynamique du don avec
l'établissement français du sang le
droit à l'autonomie n'est toujours pas
pris au bon niveau on peut se féliciter
de la démarche modestement entreprise
pour fusionner le for fait soin et le
forfait dépendance mais on ne peut pas
faire l'économ d'une réflexion sur le
forfait hébergement nous avons besoin de
garantir une meilleure protection
sociale et un meilleur service aux
personnes que ce soit à domicile ou en
établissement nous sommes loin très loin
de répondre au besoins parce qu'il n'y a
pas de véritable volonté politique vous
mettez en avant la vaccination contre le
papilloma virus et la gratuité des
préservatifs qui sont des mesures que
nous soutenons et qui ne suffisent pas à
faire une politique de santé et une
politique de protection sociale à la
hauteur et au bout du compte votre
projet est assez simple à résumé c'est
au salariés de passer à la caisse pour
financer un système affaibli vous vous
en prenez aux arrêts maladies pour
récupérer 300 millions d'euros en
donnant le pouvoir au médecin diligenté
par l'employeur face au médecin qui suit
le salarié et en squeizant complètement
le médecin conseil c'est-à-dire la
sécurité sociale vous allez également
limiter les arrêts prescrits par
téléconsultation alors même que vous
encouragez par ailleurs ce système dont
il faudrait mieux encadrer la pratique
pour qu'elle ne soit pas le cheval de
troit d'une financiarisation de la
médecine de ville vous feriez mieux de
vous interroger sur les causes des
arrêts maladies et l'on ferait mieux
d'agir vraiment pour la prévention faire
de la santé au travail une grande cause
nationale s'occuper de santé
environnementale transformer nos modes
de vie de production de consommation
nous avons également oui dire que vous
envisageiez de multiplier par de les
franchises mais vous le voyez en
attendant que nous ayons sans doute le
dos tourné pour le faire mais ce n'est
pas tout après vous être acharné à
maintenir un top niveau d'exonération
pour le capital vous venez piquer dans
les cotisations des salariés celle des
retraites complémentaires de laagire
Carco d'une part et celle de l'Unedic
d'autre part pour laagire Carco dans la
gestion est paritaire alors que les
cotisation pour seulle destination les
retraites complémentaires qui peinent à
suivre l'inflation vous vous servez
tranquille et mil000 en expliquant que
le régime vous doit bien ça puisque les
acérés cotisent plus longtemps à cause
de vous vous voulez gagner en réalité au
grattage et au tirage cela est d'autant
moins défendable qu'en augmentant les
pensions comme c'est prévu les
partenaires sociaux vont contribuer à
faire épargner au régime général les
versements du minimum contributif pour
l'Unedic après avoir réduit les droits
des salariés vous entendez prendre 11
milliards d'ici 2027 dans les
cotisations chômage des salariés pour
financer votre mauvais projet France
travail vous devenez en réalité des
spécialiste du holdup sur les
cotisations des orphèbres du cas social
comment voulez-vous que nous soutenions
un tel projet comment voulez-
vousous-même qu'il trouve ici une
majorité en réalité on a le sentiment
que ce n'est pas votre problème que vous
n'en avez cur vous voulez la sécurité
sociale rabougerie et domestiquée en
fidélité à Ambroise croisa nous voulons
l'avoir porter haut ce principe
essentiel de chacun selon ses moyens à
chacun selon ses besoins chers et chers
collègues au capitaine mon capitaine
tandis que nous parlons le temps jaloux
s'en va écrivez Horace
carpédiem cueille le jour et crois le
moins possible au lendemain avec ce que
vous semez mais il n'y aura pas
grandchose à accueillir nous ne vous
suivrons pas nous voulons croire au
lendemain si je puis dire au lendemain
qui prend
soin je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Laurent panifous du groupe Libert
indépendant Arem et
[Applaudissements]
territoire
madame la Présidente madamees messieurs
les ministres madames messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues le projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale qui nous est présenté
aujourd'hui dans un contexte de forte
inflation est porté par une volonté
d'économie plus que de réelle transition
économie alors que l'ensemble des
structures et services qu'ils soi
sanitair médicausoaux sociaux font face
à des tensions extrêmes pour recruter et
rendre attractif les carrières tout en
étant confronté au conséquen de
l'inflation que ce soit dans nos
hôpitaux ou dans nos éepades dans la
santé en général chacun s'accorde sur la
nécessité de réinvestir ces secteurs
financièrement et humainement assurément
nous en attendions davantage nous
attendions une ambition il ne s'agit pas
ici de critiquer le fait de chercher à
équilibrer le budget des comptes sociaux
particulièrement après la crise
sanitaire qui les a fragilisé mais de
dire que ces économies se font là ou de
notre point de vue il n'en faudrait pas
nous ne sommes pas semble-t-il les seuls
à le penser ce budget n'a pas réussi à
franchir le cap de la Commission et les
raisons en ce qui concerne le groupe lot
sont nombreus je pense par exemple à
l'augmentation du ticket modérateur pour
les soins dentaires est--ce prioritaire
alors que nos concitoyens connaissent
une baisse continue de leur pouvoir
d'achat je crois que notre système de
protection sociale mérite mieux que de
simples économies il a besoin aussi de
nouvelles ressources pas seulement parce
qu'il est en difficulté depuis plusieurs
années mais surtout pour faire face aux
besoins à venir qui sont croissants sur
l'accès aux soins il suffit de regarder
la situation des établissements de santé
pour comprendre que l'ONDAM 2023 et 2024
ne permettront pas de couvrir
l'inflation et les revalorisations
salariales sur les territoires
insulaires et ultramarins confrontés à
des surcûts structurels nous ne pouvons
plus repousser sans cesse la revéoration
des coefficients géographiques enfin sur
le soutien à l'autonomie qui était
pourtant affiché comme une priorité par
le Président de la République la
déception est grande ce texte ne répond
clairement pas aux enjeux liés au
vieillissement de la population le
transfert d'une fraction de CSG à la
CNSA représentera seulement 2,6
milliards d'euros en 2024 quand tous les
rapports sur ce sujet fixent les besoins
à près de 9 milliards je veux également
insister sur les métiers permettez-moi
de vous dire que la trajectoire de 50000
postes d'ici 2027 en éepad n'est pas
crédible ni réalisable au regard des
actions que vous avez engagé jusqu'ici
combien de postes ont effectivement été
financés sur les 3000 budgetés en épad
dans 2023 comment comptez-vous respecter
la trajectoire des 50000 que vous avez
annoncé d'ici 2027 alors que seulement
6000 sont prévus en
2024 pourtant nous sommes vaincu que
l'ouverture concrète de ces postes sur
les tro années à venir contribuerait à
redonner une image positive de ces
métiers à améliorer leur attractivité à
faire revenir celles et ceux si nombreux
qui l'ont quitté le plus souvent pour
des raisons de conditions de travail
c'est pourquoi je réfute l'argument
selon lequel il est inutile de créer des
postes au vu des difficultés de
recrutement actuelles je crois que vous
prenez le problème à l'envers le manque
d'attractivité de ces métiers et la
conséquence directe des conditions de
travail dans nos établissement et au
ratio d'encadrement trop faible qui
abîme et fragilise les personnels des
femmes et des hommes qui aiment pourtant
profondément leur métier mais qui
craquent et abandonnent car ils perdent
espoir c'est bien l'ampleur du désarroi
des professionnels et des structures qui
les emploient qui conduisent à une
dégradation de l'accueil des soins et de
l'accompagnement des personnes 6000
postes concrètement sur le terrain c'est
toujours moins d'un poste par
établissement le signal n'est pas bon
nous devons leur redonner confiance je
sais madamees messieurs les ministres
que nous partageons le diagnostic et la
volonté de faire en sorte que partout
sur le territoire nos aînés soient pris
en charge de la manière la plus digne
surtout c'estment cette ambition est
partagée pourquoi dans ce pfss
n'enterine-t-il pas une trajectoire
décisive et ambitieuse pour les plus
fragiles d'entre nous c'était
l'engagement du président de la
République combien de temps encore avant
de sanctuariser un financement ad hoc et
péren pour l'autonomie 3 ans après la
création de cette branche pourtant nous
vous avons fait des propositions à
commencer par la mise en place d'une
contribution spécifique via une
augmentation de la CSG sur les revenus
du capital ou bien une contribution sur
les donations et succession les plus
élevées par exemple en 20 an en ce qui
concerne les éepades nous nous
félicitons du soutien aux établissements
accueillant des personnes âgées mais
force de constater que le fond d'urgence
de 100 millions d'euros reste très
insuffisant face au taux de défaillance
inédit des établissements
notre groupe souhaite que soit revu leur
modèle de tarification il est
aujourd'hui inutilement complexe et
génère aussi des inégalité territoriale
néanmoins sur la fusion des sections
soins et dépendan une double
expérimentation permettrait de
déterminer qui des départements ou des
ARS sont les plus à même de piloter
cette nouvelle section et non seulement
les ARS comme c'est le cas dans ce
projet de loi à domicile les besoins
sont aussi importants malgré les moyens
investis par la CNSA et les département
beaucoup de structures peinent à
répondre aux demandes d'accompagnement
faute de personnel et avec l'inflation
la hausse des prix de l'énergie et
notamment de l'essence l'accompagnement
à domicile devient critique nous
souhaitons cependant souligner plusieurs
mesures positives plusieurs mesures
positives dans ce texte d'abord un volet
intéressant sur la prévention et la
lutte contre le nonreours que nous
souhaiterions d'ailleurs voir élargi aux
plus jeunes aux plus précaires aux
bénéficiaires de tous les minimas
sociaux l'accès à la vacc ation au
papillon virirus dans les collèges
ensuite sur le remboursement des
protections menstruelles réutilisables
notre groupe défendra plutôt un accès
gratuit à toutes les femmes de toutes
les protections périodiques c'est un
enjeu d'égalité et de santé publique
enfin nous étions opposés au prélèvement
sur l'gir Arco mais aussi à
l'augmentation des franchises médicales
et participation forfaitaire sur les
médicaments et consultations qui
auraient pénalisé nous le savons les
assurer les plus modestes les
complémentaires santé menancé déjà
d'augmenter leurs tarifs je veux donc
donc saluer ici la décision de ne pas
appliquer ces mesures sauf s'il s'agit
ici de reculer pour mieux sauter à
suivre je terminerai mon propos sur deux
grands absents de ce texte pour
commencer il m'est impossible de faire
l'impasse sur l'accès aux soins tout
juste effleuré dans ce budget aucune
mesure d'envergure sur la lutte contre
la désertification médicale alors que
c'est pourtant un enjeu crucial dans nos
territoires où les difficultés d'accès à
un professionnel de santé sont
grandissantes nous y revenons à chaque
fois mais l'urgence de la pénuie de
médecins et leur inégale répartition
doit être une priorité pour lutter
contre la désertification médicale il
n'y a pas de solution miracle c'est tout
un arsenal d'outils que nous devons
mettre en œuvre et de ce point de vue
l'absence de proposition est saisissante
non tout n'a pas été fait autre grand
absent de ce texte la santé mentale et
la psychiatrie nous sommes pourtant tous
conscients de l'état critique de ce
secteur essentiel silencieusement
sinistré en totale contradiction avec
l'aspir iriration de beaucoup à une
société bienveillante et du prendre soin
alors que nous sommes sortis il n'y a
pas si longtemps d'une épidémie terrible
que la situation économique et sociale
tendue abîme autant les corps que les
esprits comment expliquer cet oubli nous
regrettons ces absences voilà ce que
notre groupe souhaitait vous dire
madamees messieurs les ministres avec le
groupeot nous considérons que nous
aurions pu collectivement faire avancer
ce texte même en faisant des choix
difficiles car nous considérons que la
santé comme l'éducation est au cœur des
priorités des Français il doit faire
l'objet de toute notre attention toute
notre détermination nous le devons au
plus fragile qui espère et qui attendent
beaucoup de nous c'est pourquoi nous
regrettons le manque d'abition c'est
pourquoi nous voterons contre ce projet
de loi de financement la sécurité
sociale mes chers collègues je vous
remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Laurence
Cristol pour le groupe
Renaissance
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente messieur les
ministres madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
la rapporteur générale madame et
Messieurs les rapporteurs thématiques et
mes chers collègues nous discutons
aujourd'hui des projets de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2027 c'est-à-dire l'un des plus
puissants cimentss de notre cohésion
sociale et nationale si en 2005 Simon
may nous encourageit à pas perdre le
sens de la sécurité sociale il en va de
notre devoir d'assurer pour les
générations futures un système de
protection sociale pérenne et ambitieux
c'est pour cela que ce texte porte des
mesures d'investissement dans l'avenir
sur l'accès aux soins bien sûr mais
aussi le virage préventif la perte
d'autonomie ou le soutien à nos familles
et c'est pour un système de protection
sociale pérenne que nous refusons les
tabou et soutenons les mesures de lutte
contre les abus et les fraudes à avant
d'évoquer la branche d'autonomie je
souhaiteris dire que de nombreux députés
de notre majorité sont invesis depuis
très longtemps dans l'activité physique
adapté et nous espérons pouvoir avoir
des avancées concrètes dans ce PLFSS je
veux aussi saluer l'investissement et
l'aboutissement de réforme sur la
radiothérapie et la dialyse attendu de
longuees dates par ailleurs la presse s
fait l'écho d'une mesure majeure
techniquement difficile visant la
simplification et l'acquisition de
nouveaux droits pour les travailleurs
indépendant une concertation était en
cours les organisations patronales
est-ce que cette réforme évoquée
trouvera-t-elle sa place dans le
PLFSS j'en viens enfin à l'autonomie
pour certains qui préfèrent s'agiter
devant les micros plutôt que d'agir le
Bien Vieillir aurait disparu de l'agenda
politique ne Leurent déplaise cela fait
depuis 2020 que le Bien vieillir est au
cœur de chaque loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale portée par le
gouvernement et la la majorité c'est la
création de la 5è branche attendue
depuis des années c'est le renforcement
de l'offre ce sont des revalorisation
inédite c'est la réforme des services à
domicile et j'en passe ce sont autant de
chantiers qui avaient été laissés en
jachè par les précédentes
majorités je voudrais enfin évoquer la
question de près de 10 millions d'aidans
de notre pays après qu'il était adopté
en commission notre groupe avec mes
collègues Servan HUG et anniv
continue de proposer la prolongation de
l'expérimentation du baluchonnage avant
nous l'espérons sa
généralisation conformément à la
stratégie nationale agir pour les aidans
nous souhaitons également que
l'allocation journalière du proch aidans
aide plusieurs personnes pour
l'autonomie 3 ans après sa création la
branche continue donc de prendre corps
avec une hausse sans précédent des
moyens àoués c'est d'une hausse
exceptionnelle que les dépenses pour
l'autonomie bénéficient ce PLFSS avec
39,9 milliards qui vont continuer de
renforcer l'attractivité des métiers
adapter l'offre au besoins et améliorer
la qualité de l'accompagnement ce sont
des engagements que nous traduisons en
acte ce sont des protection face aux
épreuves de la vie que nous faisons
évoluer avec exigence d'abord les
engagements de la Conférence nationale
du handicap je pense aux 50000 solutions
nouvelles à la création d'un service
précoce de repérage d'accompagnement
prévu à l'article 38 mais aussi au
remboursement des fauteuils roulants dès
l'année prochaine je salue en cela
l'amendement du Gouvernement visant à
traduire cet engagement en lettre ce
sont également les engagements pour les
personnes âgées et là encore les
intentions passées trouvent corps dans
ce PLFSS outre les financements nouveaux
pour le domicile aus éepad nous actons
une réforme attendue de longue date pour
la mosaïque des acteurs qui
s'investissent au quoti qutiiden dans la
politique du grand âge c'est ce PLFSS
qui prévoit la réforme de financement
des éepad et nous en sommes fier nous
souhaitons néanmoins qu'une
généralisation rapide puisse enfin se
produire pour conclure je crois que de
la plus petite virgule aux sujets les
plus majeurs nous avons eu l'occasion
d'un débat de qualité et en profondeur
sur ce texte en commission et je
remercie nos collègues commissaires pour
cela nous avançons pour traduire nos
engagements et protéger notre modèle
social c'est une fierté le groupe
Renaissance votera donc évidemment ce
PLFSS je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Solen
Amot pour le groupe la France
[Applaudissements]
insoumise
le le temps de parole va commencer je
vous invite voilà merci
allez-y présidente ministre rapporteur
collègues le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2024 que nous allons étudier cette
semaine avant le 493 a été rejeté en
commission des affaires sociales je
tiens à le rappeler puisqu'il s'agit
d'une grande première depuis le premier
PLFSS de
97 ainsi nous pouvons conclure que ce
texte n'a absolument pas convaincu les
députés en commission jusque dans les
rangs de votre minorité
présidentielle en même temps je les
comprends je ne citerai pas de nom pour
éviter une chasse au sorciers aux
sorcières à Renaissance mais plusieurs
députés de vant se sont plains de ne pas
avoir eu d'amendement recevant d'avis
d'avis favorable je les comprends c'est
frustrant bienvenue dans l'opposition
chers camarades non je plaisante je
n'irai pas jusque là la place est prise
mais nous vous la laisserons bien
volontiers en
2027 pour en revenir précisément à ce
PLFSS je partage bien évidemment les
plaintes des députés macronistes aucun
des amendements ne trouve grâce à vos
yeux que ce soit ceux des insoumis ou
des autres groupes parlementaires en
effet notre groupe a déposé un grand
nombre d'amendements en commission tout
en redoutant 493 qui attend à la porte
de l'hémicycle mais ils n'ont pas trouvé
grâce à vos yeux pourtant nous ne
demandons pas le grand soir simplement
le financement de la sécurité sociale à
hauteur de ses besoins de nos besoins
afin d'augmenter les recettes nous
proposons par exemple de supprimer les
allagements de cotisation sociale
patronale nous proposons également la
création de contributions
exceptionnelles notamment sur les super
profits mais non ça ne vous plaît pas et
puis de toute façon n'en discutons pas
493 alors que notre système de santé et
de solidarité doit prendre en charge un
nombre croissant de besoins et de
dépenses alors même que celles-ci vont
s'accroître avec avec l'inflation et la
réforme coûteuse de la retraite à à 64
ans vous faites la sour d'oreille et
refusez en bloc tout ce que proposent
les les députés ici
présents le les PLFSS se succèdent et et
contribuent à l'asphyxie budgétaire des
établissements publics de santé il
suffit de lire la presse chaque jour
pour se rendre compte de l'abandon du
système de santé par le gouvernement au
printemps de cette année selon un
reportage diffusé sur les chaîne du
service public en 2 mois seulement 43
personnes sont décédées de façon
inattendue aux urgences de 22
départements en France et combien sur
toute la France tout cela à cause du
manque de personnel de moyens et à cause
de votre politique austéritaire
néolibérale autre sujet autre exemple
dans ma circonscription une personne a
dû accoucher dans sa voiture au début de
ce mois dans l'impossibilité d'accéder à
temps à la maternité en Vendé cet été ce
sont de nouveau nés qui n'ont pas
survécu à un accouchement sur
l'autoroute il faut dire qu'en 20 ans 40
% des maternités de proximité ont fermé
en France dans cette tendance à la
multiplication des des déserts
obstétricaux il reste moins de 500
maternités dans notre pays ne laissant
la place qu'aux usines à bébé quel beau
signal renvoyé à la place à la place des
femmes dans votre
politique dis-moi comment tu traites tes
vieux et je te dirai dans quelle société
tu vis cette citation de Camille bourder
Mignot et de Tatiana grünler nous parle
plus que jamais déjà l'année dernière
nous avons alerté sur la crise dans les
épades et le grand âge depuis rien n'a
bougé et 80 % des épades publiques et
associatifs n'ont pas réussi à boucler
leur budget en
2022 sans compter que le dernier
scandale avec
era accusé de maltraitance dénutrition
sous-effectifs erreur de
médicament les gestionnaires devront
répondre de leurs actes mais l'État est
responsable de la
situation enfin j'aimerais terminer par
une bombe avec effet retard la santé
mentale en France est au bord de
l'implosion dépression burnout pensé
suicidaire la santé mentale des jeunes
est en chute libre depuis la crise
sanitaire titre les principaux motifs
d'arrêt de travail des Français sont
liés à la santé mentale titre infirmière
tué au CHU de reins derrière le drame la
crise profonde de la psychiatrie en
France titre les prisons sont remplies
de personnes présentant des troubles
mentaux ou psychiques il a 15 ans déjà
le Comité consultatif national d'éthique
nous aler
on assiste à un déplacement de l'hôpital
psychiatrique vers les prisons et selon
l'OIP
détenus sur 10 présentent au moins un
trouble psychiatrique et ou une
dépendance des exemples comme cel j'en
aurai des milliers messieurs les
ministres les Français ne peuvent plus
attendre de l'enfant à la personne âgée
il n'y a que la vie et la vie ne tient
parfois qu'à un fil de suture
protégeonsla
la parole est à Monsieur thibao Bazin
pour le groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicains merci madame la Présidente
messieurs les ministres madame la
rapporteur générale madame la Présidente
de commission mes chers collègues en
complément des propos de mon collègue
yannique ner je souhaite interroger le
gouvernement sur deux points du pfss
pour 2024 pour lesquels je constate un
écart entre le discours tenu aujourd'hui
et les actes budgétaires tout d'abord je
veux revenir sur l'agerk Arco monsieur
le ministre vos propos semblent en
contradiction avec le message délivré ce
matin par
l'Élysée ma question est claire
renoncez-vous définitivement à
ponctionner l'agir Carco non seulement
aujourd'hui mais aussi demain par 493 et
dans les semaines qui viennent jusqu'à
l'adoption définitive de ce pfss pour
2024 car si vous persistez à faire payer
au salariés du privé le financement de
mesures que vous avez rajouté sans
concertation au pfss rectificative de
janvier dernier ce sera un holdup
scandaleux une ponction profondément
illégitime aussi au moment où le
dialogue avec les partenaires sociaux
est affaibli et où la confiance des
actifs dans l'avenir de notre système de
retraite est profondément abîmé notre
pays n'a pas besoin d'une telle
manipulation de fonds de caisse au-delà
de la confiance je suis convaincu que la
pérenité de notre système par
répartition passera non seulement par le
travail et la création de valeur mais
aussi par le renouvellement des
générations ce qui m'amène au 2uxème
sujet pour lequel je souhaite vous
interroger la politique familiale
l'Union nationale des associations
familiales alerte sur la revalorisation
insuffisante des prestations familiales
prévu à ce PLFSS alors que les familles
en charge d'enfants sont durement frappé
par l'inflation ainsi d'après les
données de l'UNAF en août 2022 il
fallait un couple et deux enfants 191 €
de plus qu'en août 2021 pour vivre
décemment pendant un mois or avec un
niveau d'inflation sétant maintenu à
près de 6 % entre août 2022 et août 2023
cette tendance c'est encore aggravée la
hausse affichée sur la branche famille
de plus de 2 milliards pour
2024 ne saurait faire oublier la
ponction subie en 2023 de 2 milliards si
la conjoncture économique actuelle
participe évidemment à la dégradation de
la situation des familles de notre pays
elle ne peut servir de bouc émissaire à
l'inaction des gouvernements successif
d'Emmanuel Macron en effet loin de
revenir sur les mesures néfastes
adoptées sous François Hollande votre
majorité les a confirmé en actant la
remise en cause d'universalité de la
politique familiale en mettant sous
conditions de ressources les allocations
familiales la diminution du ccient
familial de 834 €. ces deux seules
mesures ont d'après la Cour des comptes
fait peser sur les familles qui
travaillent dur un effort total proche
de 3,3 milliards soit en perte ou en
réduction de prestation soit en
augmentation d'impôt sur le revenu or
l'expérience montre que ce sont des
familles de classe moyenne qui ont le
plus durement été touché plus encore
plus encore depuis 2017 Emmanuel Macron
et sa majorité on conduit une politique
de pénalisation systématique des
familles ainsi en 2018 vous avez raboté
la prestation d'accueil du jeune enfant
pour un montant allant jusqu'à près de
546 € pour un couple dont chaque parent
travaille pour un revenu équivalent au
smque en 2020 vous avez supprimé la
majoration de l'indemnité journalière en
cas de maladie pour les parents de trois
enfants et plus ce qui représente une
perte de 30 3 % depuis 2018 vous avez
divisé par 2 sur 95 % de notre
territoire la quotité finançable du
préateau zéro pour toutes les famill de
classe moyenne qui aspirent à devenir
propriétaire et à offrir un foyer adapté
à leurs enfants ces facteurs matériels
jouent pourtant un rôle essentiel dans
la réalisation du désir d'enfants des
familles selon l'Observatoire des
familles de lunaf les mauvais résultats
de votre politique sont là en 2022
seulement 723000 enfants sont nés en
France soit le plus faible nombre de
naissances depuis laa près-gerre d'après
l'INC le taux de natalité a même
continuer de baisser au premier semestre
de 2023 à hauteur de 7 % portant notre
sol naturel à son plus bas niveau depuis
l'après-guerre pourtant la dernière
étude de l'institut kantard relative au
désir d'enfant a démonté une grande
stabilité sur les 10 dernières années du
10 désir qui s'établit à 2,3 enfants au
moment où le taux de fécondité par femme
est tombé à 1,7 enfants en 2022
cependant ce constat n'est en rien une
fatalité comme l'a écrit le démographe
du monond pour relancer la natalité il
il suffit de revenir à ce qui a fait le
succès de not politique familiale
pendant des décennies son universalité
c'est précisément ce que nous attendions
messieurs les ministres à la suite des
déclarations prometteuses de votre
collègue Aurore berger mais la déception
est immense à la lecture du projet qui
nous est soumis vous dites que la
politique familiale ne saurait devenir
une politique de redistribution mais
c'est tout le contraire que vous portez
avec votre majorité ces dernières années
vous dites vouloir lutter contre la
baisse de natalité en accompagnant
toutes les familles mais vous avez
concentré l'évolution de la réforme du
complément mode de garde en le réservant
au familles parental vous dites vouloir
réformer le congé parental mais il n'y a
aucun article dans ce pfss comme le
déplore lunaf en fait vous procrastinez
sur le sujet en évoquant un groupe de
travail alors que nous portons depuis
longtemps une proposition solide pour
qu'il soit mieux choisi mieux rémunéré
le PLFSS est un rendez-vous manqué pour
les familles le compte n'y est pas il y
a pourtant urgence quand allez-vous
enfin vraiment soutenir toutes les
familles qui travaillent quand
allez-vous enfin rétablir une véritable
politique familiale messieurs les
ministres revoyez s'il vous plaît votre
copie
je vous
[Musique]
remercie non mais je comprends madame
Fiat
mais la parole est à Madame Anne Berg
pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
démocrate madame la Présidente messieurs
les ministres madame la Présidente de la
Commission madame rapporteur général
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
thématiques chers collègues je prends
ici la suite de mon collègue Nicola
turquois et vait compléter ses propos
sur la vision qu'on les démocrates de ce
texte en évoquant le volet dépenses et
le volet prévention concernant la
prévention véritable fil rouge du projet
de loi nous saluons les avancées
concrètes à court et à moyen terme pour
améliorer la santé de nos concitoyens je
pense à notamment à la vaccination à la
campagne de vaccination pour tous les
élèves de 5e contre les infections à
papiom virirus humain à la gratuité des
préservatifs pour les moins de 26 ans ou
à la prise en charge des protections
hygiéniques réutilisables la prévention
constitue une
responsabilité collective à laquelle
puissance public prend toute sa part
mais la prévention est aussi l'affaire
de tous pour que nous soyons en tant
qu'assurés actifs dans notre gestion des
risques c'est l'objet des rendez-vous
prévention aux âges clés de de la vie
que l'article le 20 va contribuer à
généraliser en élargissant la liste des
professionnels susceptibles de réaliser
ses rendez-vous par la sensibilisation
par l'appropriation de bonnes pratiques
par la lutte contre les inégalités
sociales cet article renforce les
fondation de l'édifice de la prévention
que cette majorité construit depuis 6
ans c'est tout l'honneur de l'action
publique que d'améliorer notre santé et
préparer l'avenir des générations
futures qui bénéficieront de telles
mesures à la lecture du projet de loi on
dessa les prémisses également d'une
solidarité à la source et c'est une
excellente chose l'article 21 prévoit
ainsi l'extension simplifiée de la
complémentarité santé solidaire et à de
nouveaux allocataires de minimas sociaux
au-delà des premières expérientations en
cours notre groupe veillera à la bonne
mise en œuvre du chantier majeur de la
solidarité à la source son instauration
sera le pendant du prélèvement à la
source instauré avec succès rappelons-le
au début du quin
précédent le groupe démocrate déplore en
revanche le rejet du projet de loi en
commission incapable de présenter un
budget alternatif pour financer notre
sécurité sociale les oppositions ne
semblent réussir à se mettre d'accord
que pour réussir des coûts ou pour
mettre en difficulté la majorité c'est
de bonnne guerre mais c'est faire bien
peu de cas des
Français chers collègues de l'anupès
vous rendez-vous compte que vous avez
rejeté la création d'un service de
repérage et d'accompagnement des enfants
en situation de
handicap chers collègues de la droite
voulez-vous vraiment empêcher les
patients gravement malades d'avoir accès
plus facilement à des médicaments
innovants le groupe démocrate espérez
sincèrement pouvoir enrichir le texte
avec vous mais force de constater que
vous n'avez aucune envie de coconstruire
au regard des amendements de suppression
que vous déposez et ve sur chaque
article je ne comprends pas la
dichotomie le paradoxe complet qui
consiste à se dire ouvert au dialogue et
la construction d'un côté tout en vidant
systématiquement le texte de sa
substance de l'autre votre schizophrénie
légistique me dépasse
totalement nous le regrettons mais
continuerons d'essayer de couponstruire
dans l'intérêt des
Français si nous salons
non non non non s'il vous plaît la
parole est à Madame bergant chacun prend
la parole s'il vous plaît à tour de rôle
le but étant que chacun se respecte et
s'écoute donc je vous remercie s'il vous
plaît je madame Fiat s'il vous plaît je
vous demande un peu plus de calme vous
êtes pourtant pas trop nombreux ce soir
donc
voilà un peu de calme s'il vous plaît la
parole est à Madame bergante on l'écoute
allez-y s'il vous plaît si nous saluons
les nombreuses avancées pour la
protection sociale des Français propos
par ce texte le groupe démocrate
considère qu'il est possible d'aller
plus loin dans plusieurs domaines tout
d'abord dans le soutien aux famille
notre collègue pine Goulet a ainsi
déposé un amendement visant à augmenter
la prime de naissance à l'arrivée du
premier enfant
accueillir un enfant pour la première
fois engendre de nombreux frais comme
l'achat de vêtements et d'équipements
qui peuvent toutefois être ensuite
amortis avec les enfants suivants son
amendement propose donc une prime
différenciée selon l'ordre de naissance
à cou égal accompagner les familles
c'est également assurer l'effectivité de
certains droits comme le congé paternité
par exemple trop d'agriculteurs font
face à des contraintes qui les empêchent
de bénéficier de ce temps précieux
auprès de leurs enfant l'amendement de
Nicolas turquois vise donc à leur
accorder davantage de flexibilité dans
la prise de congé paternité nous
appelons également à une réforme de
l'assiette des cotisations sociales dont
s'acquitent les travailleurs
indépendants comme nous l'avions déjà
défendu lors de la la réforme des
retraites en début d'année il s'agit
d'un enjeu majeur d'équité et de justice
sociale face au fléau de l'obésité du
diabète et plus largement des maladies
chroniques l'essentiel du groupe
démocrate a soutenu l'excellent travail
de notre collègue Cyril Isaac cbil mené
de manière transpartisane lors du
printemps de l'évaluation nous avons
réussi à faire adopter en commission des
affaires sociales deux amendements sur
le sujet le premier porte sur un
durcissement de la taxe soda notamment
en abaissant le nombre de paliers de
taxation de 15 à3 et le second
amendement a trait à la création d'une
contribution sur les produits
alimentaires transformés lorsque ceci
présente un fort tau de sucre ajouté
enfin je porte aussi un amendement
visant à inclure la prévention par le
sport et par la nutrition entre autres
dans le forfait soin des épades une
attente forte des acteurs du secteur les
démocrates poursuivront aujourd'hui
comme à l'avenir ces chantiers
primordiaux pour nombre de nos
concitoyens et ce dans le but de
préserver renforcer et protéger notre
précieux modèle social un objectif qui
semble clairement menacé par des
opportunistes de tout bord notre groupe
votera résolument en faveur de ce projet
de loi je vous
remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
François Gernigon pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
horizon
merci madame la
Présidente messieurs les ministres
madame la Présidente de la Commission
affaires sociales madame la rapporteur
chers
collègues comme l'ont souigné plusieurs
de mes collègues le PLFSS pour 2024
intervient dans un contexte budgétaire
particulièrement serré les dépenses
sociales prévu pour atteindre plus de
630 milliards d'euros l'année prochaine
dépasse le budget de l'État
une réalité importante à
souligner il est manifeste que nous
sommes à un carrefour où chaque décision
compte nous ne pouvons plus permettre de
dépenser sans compter sans s'inscrire
dans une stratégie claire et une vision
à long
terme malgré ces contraintes le
gouvernement par le pfss investit là où
c'est
nécessaire il est le reflet de notre
engagement à soutenir et intensifier les
politiques sociales mises en œuvre de
depuis
2017 il reconnaît et valorise le travail
des professionnels de santé notamment en
revalorisant la pénibilité des horaires
difficiles la nuit les dimanches les
jours fériers dans les secteurs
sanitaires et médicos-sociaux en
proposant une refonte des modèles de
financement pour les adapter aux enjeux
contemporains tels que la réforme
cruciale du financement des éepades et
une lutte contre la fraude
sociale il est cependant regrettable que
que des jeux politiques et conduit
certains à refuser le P FSS en
commission c'est basse manœuvre loin des
véritables enjeux trahissent une forme
de
duplicité comment expliquer qu'ils
rejettent un texte auquel ils ont
eux-mêmes contribué par de nombreux
amendements après 35 heur de débat
constructif 11 1176 amendements ont été
examinés et 95 ont été
adopté cette contradiction est
révélatrice de postur Politi
plutôt que d'une véritable volonté de
servir l'intérêt
général l'un des points importants de ce
PLFSS et sa démarche en matière de
prévention il vise à améliorer l'accès
au vaccin notamment contre le
papiomavirus qui sera désormais plus
aisément accessible surtout dans le
cadre de la campagne de vaccination
organisé pour les élèves des collèges
garantir la gratuité des préservatifs
pour les jeunes lutter contre contre la
précarité menstruelle et déployer des
bilans de prévention pour des moments
clés de la
vie sur ce dernier point j'aimerais
insister sur un amendement que j'ai
déposé et qui a été approuvé par la
commission il concerne la prise en
charge le diagnostic et la prévention
des problèmes d'audition lors de lors
des trois bilans aux trois âches clés
que nous avons communément voté l'an
dernier dans le cadre du PLFSS
2023 la ité qui intervient très jeune
plus tard dans le monde professionnel et
puis pour les âgés pour les plus âgés de
65 ans 6 personnes sur 10 est un enjeu
dans cé publique
majeur c'est une question qui mérite
toute notre attention dans notre combat
pour l'autonomie et la qualité de la vie
des
seigneurs nous devons reconnaître
l'importance de cette problématique et
agir en
conséquence enfin ce pelfss s'engage en
faveur du remboursement intégral des
fauteuils électriques roulants une
promesse tenue et surtout attendue suite
à l'annonce du président lors de la
dernière conférence nationale sur le
handicap une une avancée majeure pour
plus de justice
sociale chers collègues certains
estiment toujours que ces mesures sont
insuffisantes mais c'est par notre
détermination à améliorer notre système
de protection sociale sans faille que
année après année depuis le depuis
nous investissons pour améliorer le
quotidien des professionnels des
établissements et pardessus tout des
Français le groupe Horizon est apparenté
considère ce texte comme un équilibre
entre
responsabilité réformme nécessairire et
nouveaux droits il est d'autant plus
regrettable que certains a choisi de le
rejeter après tendeur de débat rich et
constructif je vous
remercie je vous
remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Sébastien Pali
pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame la Présidente
messieurs les ministres madame la
Présidente de la Commission et Madame la
rapportrice générale qui n
pas qu'est-ce donc que la sécurité
sociale je c définir ainsi la garantie
donnée à chacun qu'il disposera en
toutes circonstances d'un revenu
suffisant pour assurer à lui-même et à
sa famille une existence décente ou à
tout le moins un minimum
vital ces mots de Pierre
laroc ces mots de Pierre laroc l'un des
pères fondateurs de notre sécurité
sociale remonte à presque 80 ans mais
raisonne encore particulièrement
aujourd'hui car notre premier constat
c'est que le budget pour la sécurité
sociale que nous examinons aujourd'hui
ne permet ni d'assurer une existence
descente ni même le minimum vital il ne
le permet pas alors qu'il faudrait au
moins 2 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires pour que les personnes
handicapés n'est pas 90 % de probabilité
d'être pauvre il ne le permet pas alors
qu'il faudrait 6 milliards de plus pour
permettre à chacun et à chacune de
vieillir dignement sans maltraitance il
ne le permet pas alors qu'il faudrait de
milliards de plus pour sa assurer que
des femmes ne soient plus contraintes
d'accoucher au bord de la route comme ce
fut déjà le cas dans ma circonscription
en Dordogne certes les moins de 26 ans
pourront disposer gratuitement de
préservatifs et de protection
menstruelle réutilisable ce que nous
saluons mais ce saupoudrage de quelques
mesures bénéfiques ne parvient pas à
cacher l'ambition derrière ce projet de
loi celle de maintenir notre système de
santé dans une détresse financière
chronique car derrière toute annonce
d'augmentation de moyens se cache au
mieux une stagnation des dépenses au
pire un budget incapable de compenser
l'inflation la façon dont est construit
ce PLFSS et d'ailleurs à l'image du
rigorisme budgétaire et du coup prê
austéritaire que votre parti a
systématiquement dégainé dès lors que
nous appelions à de réels
investissements pour notre système de
soins nous faisons face à une
augmentation des besoins avec exactement
les mêmes moyens ce n'est non seulement
pas viable financièrement mais c'est une
constante mise en
de notre système de soins et des
bénéficiaires nous ne pouvons pas
aborder la question du financement de la
prévention dans ce PLFSS cloisonné
puisque cela relève du projet de loi des
finances alors que le coût de la
pollution le coût de la pollution de
l'air est de 100 milliards d'euros par
an les crédits dédiés à la prévention
dans le projet de loi de financeces se
réduisent à seulement 223 millions
d'euros si vous vous demandez pourquoi
je parle du PLF aujourd'hui c'est parce
que nous devons justement prendre de la
hauteur car ce n'est pas seulement notre
austérité budgétaire que nous remettons
en cause mais aussi le fonctionnement
même des lois de finances de ce pays qui
sont incapables de projeter le monde de
demain le vote par le Parlement du
budget pour l'état de la sécurité
sociale ser r se résume à un jeu à somme
nulle où toute dépense est
irrémédiablement censurée ainsi dans le
monde absurde des lois de finances nous
voulons accélérer la transition
écologique des des établissements de
santé nous devons par exemple
ponctionner dans le budget dédié au
ferroviaires loin d'assurer la stabilité
financière de notre pays ce RA fistolage
permanent où nous devons déshabiller
Paul pour habiller Jacques encourage la
mise en péril de notre système de soins
et d'accompagnement vous me direz que ce
n'est pas vous qui avez fixé les règles
et je vous le concède mais vous vous en
accommodez très bien car il répond
parfaitement à votre logique froide de
maîtrise des dépenses pour asphyier
notre système de santé alors que chaque
année nous perdons 140 milliards d'euros
en exonération fiscale et sociale le
gouvernement cache dans une main les
milliards d'euros de recettes possible
et de l'autre fait une petite te sur
l'épaule des Français en leur disant
qu'il faut faire des efforts et
travailler plus longtemps nous aimerions
croire que vous avez enfin retenu la
leçon de la crise du coronavirus qui
n'étte que les conséquences tragiques
des activités humaines sur notre santé
renforcé par l'abandon de nos hôpitaux
publics nous aimerions croire que c'est
par mes connaissances du coût de
l'exposition de la population aux
risques environnementaux que vous ne
savez pas qu'investir dans une politique
de santé environnementale c'est la
manière la plus durable de réduire nos
dépenses mais vous le savez et si vous
n'investissez pas dans une protection
sociale résiliante à même d'intégrer la
protection de l'environnement et de la
santé humaine ce n'est pas par
méconnaissance mais par dogmatisme ù la
survie de notre système de santé est
suspendue à votre logique courttermisme
qui ne voit pas plus haut que la
prochaine échéance électorale
la différence fondamentale entre le
groupe écologiste et votre majorité et
la droite de cet hémicycle c'est que
pour vous prendre soin aussi bien de la
santé de la population que de notre
planète ne sera jamais un investissement
mais une dépense une charge et une
contrainte financière qu'il convient de
maîtriser nous voilà donc ici à devoir
nous donner à vous donner des leçons de
comptabilité car oui prévenir les
risques c'est dépenser de l'argent
maintenant pour éviter d'en dépenser
ensuite cela revient donc a dépenser de
l'argent sans en voir les résultats
immédiats et ça ça ne rentre pas dans
votre matrice étriquée qui vénère
l'augmentation du PIB au cè prê comme le
saingral votre gouvernement soutient
mordicus qu'il n'y a aucune alternative
si ce n'est de se serrer la ceinture
pour les 4 ans à venir mais faire en
sorte que la dignité n'est de prix pour
personne ne sera jamais une question de
contrainte budgétaire mais bel et bien
de choix que nous assumons pleinement
nous assumons d'appeler à ce que l'accès
à la pleine santé pour toutes et tous
soit la boussole de ce PLFSS et de tous
les autres et cela passe nécessairement
par remettre la prévention au cœur de
nos préoccupations budgétaire la
prévention ne se résume pas à une ligne
budgétaire dans le PLF c'est une grille
de lecture qui est d'ailleurs très
révélatrice des priorités de ce
gouvernement vaut-il mieux renouveler
les cadeaux fiscaux à l'industrie
agroalimentaire qui sponsorise encore la
malbouffe ou investir dans une
alimentation saine local et bio qui
n'empoisonne pas nos enfants vaut-il
mieux dépenser pour construire une
autoroute inutile polluante TER
responsable de l'augmentation des
maladies chroniques ou vaut-il mieux
enfin faire de la santé environnementale
une priorité vaut-il mieux faire la
chasse aux arrêt maladies ou
s'interroger sur les causes
structurelles de leur inflation alors
que l'emploi précaire a été multiplié
par 2 en 40 ans nous appelons à nous
poser les bonnes questions et à sortir
d'un PLFSS qui fonctionne en silo alors
que vous nous venons de vivre l'été le
plus chaud jamais enregistré et que
l'année prochaine sera probablement un
nouveau record nous avons besoin d'un un
véritable Big Bang de la protection
sociale parce que nous avons besoin d'un
pays qui abandonne qui abonde la
sécurité sociale comme une richesse et
renforce le service public comme notre
patrimoine à toutes et à tous parce que
nous avons besoin d'un pays où il sera
possible d'obtenir un rendez-vous chez
le médecin le jour même à 30 minutes
maximum de chez soi parce que nous avons
besoin d'un pays où l'État sera dans
l'obligation de rénover d'ici un an
chacun des 5 millions de foyers en
précarité énergétique ces propositions
ne sont ni e ni déconnecté du PLFSS face
à l'effondrement climatique qui a d'ors
et déjà commencé cette utopie réaliste
d'une protection sociale et écologique
qui intègre pleinement la Santé de la
population et des écosystèmes et notre
unique bouée de sauvetage pour pouvoir
vivre digement sur une planète
respirable et le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale que
vous nous présentez aujourd'hui est à
l'antithèse de cet horizon désirable
pour préserver la santé humaine avec un
budget qui brille par son aveuglement
face à à l'urgence climatique qui met en
péril notre santé et celle des plus
vulnérables comment la majorité
peut-elle s'étonner que nous rejetions
le texte en commission alors non
seulement nous l'avons rejeté en
commission mais nous refuserons
aujourd'hui à nouveau d'être les otages
de cette mise en scène cfcayenne d'un
budget inconscient digne du monde
d'avant je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Victor castor pour le groupe Gauche
démocrate et républicaine
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre monsieur le ministre de la
Santé chers
collègues ce budget est comme l'ensemble
de votre politique en décalage et ne
prend absolument pas la mesure des
besoins sanitaires et sociaux dans nos
territoires et particulièrement Guyane
ce décalage est habissal le PLFSS pour
2024 annonce renforcer l'attractivité
des métiers dans les établissements de
santé en guyan au-delà de l'attractivité
c'est la fidélisation des personnels
qu'il faut favoriser cela passe par des
projets de recherche propre à nos
pathologies par l'installation
d'équipements structurant performant par
la formation et le recrutement local sur
ces points pour notorit aucune réponse
aucune proposition de votre
de votre gouvernement ni dans le PLF ni
dans le PLFSS aucune rien sur la
construction d'un hôpital neuf capable
d'accueillir le CHRU de Guyane vous
préférez construire sur des parkings et
mettre des mobilom partout ce budget
prévoit en outre d'accélérer le virage
de la prévention à tous les étages du
système de santé cette ambition devrait
être la même partout et pour tous or
force de constater que dans dans nos
pays les moyens mis en place sont à
géométrie variable l'exemple du
dépistage du cancer colorectal est
révélateur les habitants de la Guyane et
plus particulièrement des localités sans
voies terrestre ne disposent ni de
laboratoire ni d'hôpitaux et sont donc
condamnés à être diagnostiqué trop tard
au surplu votre choix unilatéral de
transfert des analyses vers un
laboratoire hexagonal soit à plus de 10
heures d'acheminement ne permet pas de
déceler la présence de cellules
cancéreuses ce qui rend de fait ces
prélèvements non analysables ainsi pour
la période de 2021 à 2022 seulement 8 %
du public cible a pu se faire dépister
en Guyane pour un taux de 35 % pour
l'ensemble de la France en y ajoutant
l'absence de transport vers les communes
isolé guyanaises il ne dépassera pas les
3 % pour la période 2022-
20023 favoriser la prévention comme
annoncé dans le PLFSS impose des mesures
adaptées à nos territoires à défaut il
s'agit d'une mise en danger en
connaissance de cause de la vie de tous
ceux qui résident à plus de 7000 km de
Paris mise en danger de nos populations
assumées dans le volet préventif mise en
danger délibéré dans le curatif où
depuis 2015 et encore aujourd'hui un
arrêté préfectoral a mis un terme à la
collecte du sang sur le territoire de
Guyane sans que de nombreuses et sans
que les nombreuses all et interpellation
politique médical et associative n'y
changer rien ce budget souhaite enfin
encourager la sobriété dans
l'utilisation du système de santé pour
la Guyane ça ça signifie tout simplement
appauvrir le système de santé d'ors et
déjà
indigeent cela madame la Première
ministre est scandaleux et irresponsable
aujourd'hui du fait de l'enclavement des
personnes meurent en Guyane pour
l'unique raison qu'il est impossible de
les évacuer vers un hôpital du littoral
mais compte tenu de l'obsolescence et de
l'insuffisance des plateaux techniques
de l'hôpital de Cayenne l'évacuation
doit souvent être orientée vers la
Martinique ou vers Paris les délais
difficultés de mise en place de ces
évacuations amoindrissent drastiquement
les chances de survie des patients
d'autant que tous les prétextes sont
bons pour que la sécurité sociale refuse
ces évacuations sanitaires au point que
des associations de malades se
constituent atteint de pathologie lourd
et ell ne cesse de nous interpeller en
la
matière situation absurde indécente
intenable les adjectifs ne manquent pas
pour qualifier l'état de délabrement
avancé du système de santé en guyan et
pourtant que prévoit le PLF que prévoit
le PLFSS en terme d'investissement
structurel pour nos territoir vos textes
ne prévoi rien et renvoie comme
d'habitude à des ordonnances
technocratiques prise de façon
discrétionnaire dans vos cabinets
feutrés il est temps pour nos territoir
de mener des projets d'ampleur d'avoir
une vision cohérente qui prennent en
compte la réalité du terrain en Guan la
réalité est celle d'un territoire grand
comme le Portugal en sousdéveloppement
chronique qui nécessite une politique
d'aménagement à la hauteur des enjeux
démographiques nous avons une population
qui va doubler d'ici 20 ans mais que
peut-on attendre d'un gouvernement
autoritaire qui refuse le débat et qui
brandit le 493 à la moindre secousse
rien il n'y a rien à attendre de vous et
ça nos pays l'ont bien compris vous
répétez que les outremèes sont la
grandeur de la France mais entendez-vous
les aspirations des peuples qui
vivent je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Paul
André Colombani pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outre mer et territoire
[Applaudissements]
sur monsieur saintu surveillez monsieur
saintu
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
chers collègues ce PLFSS 2024 n'est pas
un grand cru c'est un euphémisme de le
dire c'est la première fois que le texte
n'est pas voté en commission et
incessamment sous peu un 493 devrait un
trèom pour ns débats le texte que vous
avez présenté cette année est très loin
d'être à la hauteur des enjeux d'un
système de santé qui ne cesse de se
détériorer il prévoit certes de réaliser
des économies pour un montant de 3,5
milliards d'euros mais à quel prix au
prix de l'accès aux soins et de
l'intérêt des assurés sociaux au prix de
au prix de l'accès aux soins d'abord en
effet si l'ondame augmente cette
augmentation parviendra péniblement à
compenser l'inflation et aucune des
mesures que vous proposez n'est n'est de
nature à améliorer substantiellement
l'accès aux soins dans nos territoires
vous connaissez bien le refin puisque
nous le répétons chaque année il faut
davantage de moyens humain et financier
pour l'hôpital public si la question se
pose dans tous les territoires elle est
encore plus pr an en Outremer et en
Corse depuis 2017 le coefficient
géographique de nos hôpitaux n'a pas été
relevé il s'agit pourtant du principal
levier permettant de rattraper les
retards structurels mais également de
compenser les surcûts et les effets de
seuil liés à l'insularité il est urgent
de le réhausser je prendrai l'exemple de
ce CHU de Guadeloupe où l'on doit
arbitrer entre le financement de la
recherche ou le paiement des
fournisseurs nous avions par ailleurs
proposé que ce coefficient soit fixé
chaque année par le PLFSS pour ne pas
éluder ce débat comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui je note cependant avec
intérêt la proposition de Monsieur le
Ministre de la Santé et me tient son
entière disposition pour travailler sur
ce dossier qui est un marqueur politique
important pour notre groupe
lot ce pfss réalise également des
économies au détriment de l'intérêt du
patient hôpital public et médecine de
ville sublissent de PI de plein fouet
les conséquences de cette logique
d'économie budgétaire sous couvert d'un
renforcement de modalités de lutte
contre la fraude nous constatons en fait
un affaiblissement des droits des
assurés sociaux j'en veux pour preuve
l'article 27 qui contient plusieurs
mesures qui sont autant de ligne rougge
il prévoit notamment la possibilité de
mettre fin aux arrêts de malade de
travail sur la base d'un rapport rendu
par un médecin diligenté par l'employeur
tout ceci en l'appelant un examen
médical par un médecin conseil on ouvre
la porte ici à des conflit d'intérêt
majeur j'ai proposé lors des débats en
commission de créer un agrément qui
serait délivré par par l'assurance
maladie au médecin etyant suivi une
formation spécifique en l'absence d'un
contrôle effectué effectué par un
praticien conseil il est il est dans
l'intérêt de l'assurer que ce contrôle
médical soit pratiqué par un médecin
agréé et donc formé à ce genre de
situation de même en proposant que le
contrôle de du service médical puisse
être effectué par délégation de tâche
votre texte abdique face au manque de
moyens humains l'idée que des idé ind
journalière d'un salarié puisse être
suspendu sur la base d'un simple coup de
téléphone sans examen médical est
inacceptable il faut au contraire
recruter de nouveaux praticiens conseil
pour assurer un contrôle efficace toutes
les solutions que nous avons été proposé
non nous avons proposé n'ont pas été
retenus nos inquiétudes sont pourtant
vives notamment en ce qui concerne
l'article 27 dont l'alinéa 4 Bafou le
principe du contradictoire pour les
médecins libéraux sanctionnés par la
CPAM et cristallise la colère des
médecins dans dans un contexte déjà très
tendu par l'échec de renouvellement de
la
convention ainsi il prévoit la suspens
la suppression de l'avis de la
commission des pénalités financières
afin de réduire les délais d'instruction
et prive donc les médecins de se
défendre de manière équitable c'est
disproportionné et va même à l'encontre
de l'esprit de la lettre de cadrage du
ministre de la Santé je pourrais vous en
dire autant de l'article 7 qui ouvre la
porte au délis statistiques pénalisant
des praticiens qui font face aux affluxs
importants
de patientell notamment dans les déserts
médicaux il appelle selon moi une
caractérisation plus précise de la
fraude permettant de sanctionner les
fraudeur mais sans jeter l'pre sur
l'ensemble de la profession relevons
tout de même certaines mesures que nous
voyons d'un bon œil le renforce le
renforcement de la du volet prévention
avec notamment la vaccination contre le
papiomavirus au au collège ainsi que
l'accès gratuit au préservatifs et au
protection menstruelle réutilisable mais
vous l'avez compris nous considérons que
le compte n'y est pas que si la copie
n'est pas revue sur la base des
marqueurs que nous avons défendu nous
opposerons à ce texte je vous remercie
je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Emmanuel
[Applaudissements]
Ménard merci
beaucoup
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres chers collègues le déficit de
la Sécurité sociale sera plus important
que prévu en 2023 et en 2024 cette année
il est donc estimé à 8,8 milliards
d'euros contre 8,2 milliards prévus en
avril dernier il devrait atteindre 11,2
milliards en 2024 au lieu des 9,6
milliards prévus et ça ne va pas
s'arranger face à ces mauvais résultats
vous nous annoncez 3,5 milliards
d'économies faites notamment sur les
actes de biologie les soins dentaires
avec la modification du ticket
modérateur ou le prix des médicaments
malheureusement cela ne suffira pas
difficile d'équilibrer un budget quand
les besoins ne cessent d'augmenter mais
que en face les crédits annoncés ne sont
pas à la hauteur des enjeux de notre
époque population vieillissante nombre
d'assurés sociaux atteints de maladie
chronique en augmentation et cetera
autant de sujets de questions même qui
restent sans réponse en matière d'accès
au soins la situation est tubuesque
alors que de nombreux Français vivent
dans des déserts médicaux et que
certains d'entre eux sont découragés par
des délais d'attente beaucoup trop longs
des professionnels de santé sont obligés
de refuser des patients la Direction de
la recherche des études de l'évaluation
et des statistiques l'adresse a publié
en mai dernier une étude qui relève que
près de 80 % des médecins généralistes
libéraux juge aujourd'hui insuffisante
l'offre de médecine générale dans leur
zone d'exercice et 65 % d'entre eux ont
déclaré avoir refusé de nouveaux
patients en 2022 ils étaient 53 % en
2019 alors qu'attendez-vous monsieur le
ministre qu'attendez-vous pour supprimer
le numérus apertus de grâce ouvrez les
portes de nos universités aux étudiants
en médecine et donner-leur les moyens
d'étudier en France autre sujet majeur
je l'ai dit le vieillissement de la
population française le nombre de
Français âgés de 75 à 84 ans aura
augmenté de 50 % entre 2020 et 2030 vous
nous annoncez poursivre le virage
domiciliaire en clair la possibilité
pour les personnes âgées de se faire
soigner chez elle avec des moyens
supplémentaires pour la création de
nouvelles places de servicees de soins
infirmierers à domicile mais est-ce à la
hauteur de l'enjeu je
m'interroge un mot encore pour les
grands oubliés de ce projet de loi les
soins palliatifs alors qu'un texte sur
la fin de vie englobant c'est du moins
ce qu'on nous annonce soins palliatifs
et euthanasie devrai arriver au
Parlement au début de l'année 2024 or
s'il y a bien un consensus en France
c'est sur la nécessité l'impératif
l'exigence du développement des soins
palliatifs selon les chiffres officiels
entre 150000 et 200000 personnes
auraient besoin de soins palliatifs en
France des chiffres qui vont
mécaniquement augmenter à la mesure du
vieillissement de notre population or 25
ans après la loi du 9 juin 1999 censé
garantir à toute personne malade dont
l'état le requierre le droit d'accéder à
des soins palliatifs et à un
accompagnement 21 départements sont
toujours dépourvus d'unité de soins
palliatif visiblement ce n'est pas une
priorité pour vous autre oublié de ce
projet de loi les familles l'article 10
du texte diminue de 0,5 % la côte
partart de taxe sur les salaires
actuellement affectés à la caisse
nationale d'allocation familiale la knaf
réduisons ainsi les recettes de la
branche famille de 92 milliards d'euros
dès 2024 avec en parallèle la péren a du
transfert décidé en 2023 du coût des
indemnités journalières lié au congé
maternité post-natale à la branche
famille pour un montant de 2 milliards
d'euros bref plus de dépenses pour moins
de recettes et rien non plus sur le
congé parental cours mieux rémunéré
qu'annoncé la ministre AORE berger à
grand renfort de communication une
réforme pourtant attendue par beaucoup
de
famille je ne peux conclure mon propos
sans un mot sur la frate sociale le coût
des arrêts maladies abondit de de 8,2 %
hors covid en 2022 et il serait l'une
des causes principales du dérapage des
soins de ville en 2023 la Cour des
comptes a en outre chiffré les
malversations aux prestations sociales
de l'ordre de 6 à 8 milliards d'euros
annuels alors que les contrôles
mobilisent moins de 3400 agents dans
l'ensemble des caisses pour renforcer
ces contrôles vous vous engagez à créer
1500 postes dédiés au contrôle fiscal
d'ici à 2027 et 1000 agents seront
chargés de la lutte contre la fraude au
sein des caisses de sécurité sociale des
annonces qui vont dans le bon sens
malheureusement le 493 annoncé nous
empêchera de renforcer ce dispositif par
nos amendements sans commentaire je vous
remercie je vous
remercie nous avons donc terminé avec
les prises de parole de chaque groupe la
parole est à Madame la rapporteur
général merci merci Madame la la
présidente quelques mots en retour de ce
qu'on a pu entendre depuis le début de
cette discussion générale d'abord
d'abord j'ai une pensée pour les
soignants je sais pas pour ceux qui nous
regardent mais ceux qui sont sûrement en
train de de travailler de les remercier
qu'il soi en ville à l'hôpital et
d'ailleurs redire ici que les
remerciements ce ne sont pas que des
mots que nous les avons revalorisé dans
le cadre du segéur c'était 10 milliards
dans le cadre de ce PLFSS c'est plus de
2 milliards sur les révalorisations
annoncées pendant l'année c'est aussi
l'augmentation du des points d'indice je
rappelle ici 1,5 points plus les 5
points plus l'augmentation sur les
points sur les bas salaires mais je
pense à eux sur la hauteur des débats
qu'on a pu avoir ce soir et je crois que
nos débats qui vont commencer prendrai
un intérêt pour eux si on acceptait de
considérer que la situation de nos
établissements ne dépend pas uniquement
euh de la situation financière de ces
établissements oui il faut de l'argent
c'est ce que nous avons fait je le redis
ici un name à 254 milliards pour 2024 en
augmentation de 3,2 % c'est aussi une
pensée pour les soignants mais acceptons
de dire que la démographie médicale qui
est en
augmentation dans les années qui
viendront avec la fin du numérus clusus
que nous avons arrêté euh et une des
raisons aussi et la ature des débats que
j'ai pu parfois entendre lors de cette
discussion n'est pas la hauteur à mon
avis de nos
soignants sur l'agir Carco je vais
revenir sur ce qu'il existe dans le
texte concernant l'agir Carco le texte
ne prévoit pas de de ponction mais
définit un cadre conventionnel à
l'article 9 dans lequel les
représentants peuvent fixer la
contribution au financement de la
fermeture des réseaux des des régimes
spéciaux et de la solid éé au sein au
sein si sur la base d'un accord c'était
important pour moi de rappeler ici ce
qu'il existe dans ce texte que nous
allons examiner et enfin on a parlé de
la santé mentale vous étiez invité au
compte de Ségure et le ministre nous a
appelé à faire des propositions sur la
santé mentale je crois pour ma part que
nous avons à soutenir évidemment ce
secteur comme certains l'ont dit dans
l'urgence et notamment le secteur des
des soins sous contrainte euh j'avais
proposé qu'une mesure qui permette aux
psychologues experts puissent partager
les tâches des psychiatres dans les
tâches administratives de ces secteurs
c'est une mesure qui ne rentre pas dans
le PLFSS et ça pour vous dire que toutes
les la politique de santé ou les mesures
que nous parlementaires nous pouvons
adopter au travers de proposition de loi
de travaux de la que nous pouvons faire
en commission sont aussi devant nous et
que nous avons à continuer à travailler
continuer à travailler face à ces défis
de la démographie qui est vraiment
devant nous mais très proche travaillons
ensemble sur ces sujets qui à mon sens
ne devrait pas faire l'objet de
caricature de débat de politique
politicienne les citoyens et nos
soignants nous attendent
merci et la parole est à madame la
Première
ministre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre vous avez la
parole merci madame la présidente madame
la Présidente de la Commission des
affaaires sociales madame la rapporteur
générale Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés l'adoption du projet doit de
financement pour la sécurité sociale est
essentielle pour notre pays c'est la
capacité pour beaucoup de nos
concitoyens de se soigner c'est le
fonctionnement de nos hôpitaux et le
salaire des soignants qui y travaillent
c'est l'accompagnement des jeunes
enfants et des familles c'est le soutien
aux personnes en situation de handicap
et au plus fragile c'est l'aide au plus
démunis ce sont les retraites de nos
aînés c'est l'autonomie des personnes
âgées le PLFSS est bien plus qu'un
budget c'est de notre modèle social dont
il est question c'est chaque année
l'occasion de le moderniser de
l'améliorer de l'adapter aux attentes de
nos
concitoyens ce PLFSS c'est près de 3
milliards d'euros supplémentaires en
2023 pour l'objectif national
d'assurance maladie
lâ c'est ation supérieure à l'inflation
pour l'année
prochaine ce PLFSS c'est un
investissement de plus de 640 milliards
d'euros en
2024 comme l'année dernière il consacre
des des moyens croissants à notre
sécurité sociale nous accentuons nos
actions sur la prévention nous faisons
évoluer le financement de l'hôpital nous
ouvrons la voie à une réforme du
financement des épades nous renforçons
la lutte contre la
fraude sur ce texte si important pour le
quotidien des Français une fois de plus
comme toujours nous avons tenté de
trouver des points
d'accord les ministres ont échangé en
amont avec tous les groupes
parlementaire une fois de plus comme
toujours nous avons fait évoluer notre
texte et accepter des amendements de la
majorité comme des
oppositions sur cette deuxème partie du
PLFSS consacré aux recettes des
amendements permettront d'enrichir les
dispositifs de lutte contre la
fraude d'améliorer d'améliorer les
d'améliorer et c'est important les
droits des travailleurs indépendant de
simplifier les démarches d'affiliation
et de paiement des cotisations des
agriculteurs
de tirer les conséquences de la réforme
des lycées professionnels quant au
régime social des allocations versé au
lycéen ou de sécuriser pour les
industriels le niveau des contributions
pharmaceutiques pourtant malgré nos
ouvertures une fois de
plus l'usage selon lequel les GR
d'opposition refuse de voter un budget
quel qu'il soit a prévalu nous l'avons
encore mesuré en
commission si cette deuxème partie du
PLFSS n'est pas adoptée nous ne pourrons
pas examiner sa trème partie
c'est-à-dire les mesures concrètes de
protection sociale pour les
français si cette deuxème partie du
plsss pas ad nous priverons tout notre
modèle social de ces ressources avec mon
gouvernement je m'y
refuse aussi sur le fondement de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur la deuxè partie du
projet doit de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2024 je vous
[Applaudissements]
remercie je vous remercie madame la
Première
ministre l'Assemblée nationale prend de
la responsabilité du gouvernement
conformément aux dispositions de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution le texte sur lequel la
première ministre engage la
responsabilité du gouvernement sera
insérée en annexe au compte-rendu de la
présente séance en application de
l'article 155 alinéa 1er du règlement le
débat sur le texte est immédiatement
suspendu ce texte sera considéré comme
adopté sauf si une motion de censure
déposée avant demain 18h30 et voter dans
les conditions prévues à l'article 49 de
la Constitution dans l'hypothèse où une
motion de censure serait déposée la
Conférence des Présidents fixera la date
et les modalités de sa discussion la
séance est
levée